This episode is brought to you by Lloyd's business and commercial banking. One of the great things about finance is that it may result in you having to pay tax. And this was a constant grumble in Anglo-Saxon England, which was the most heavily taxed country in the whole of Christendom. And just when the Anglo-Saxons thought it couldn't get any worse, they got conquered by King Canute. And Canute imposed a tax rate that was effectively... 100%. Yeah, well, that was one very big change, Tom, but another tax change is upon us. And this is the advent of making tax digital for income tax. And if you're at all concerned about it, this is where Lloyd's come in, because they're here to help make that change much
本集由劳埃德商业和企业银行赞助播出。金融的一大妙处在于，它可能会让你不得不纳税。这在盎格鲁-撒克逊时期的英格兰是一个永恒的抱怨，当时它是整个基督教世界中税负最重的国家。而就在盎格鲁-撒克逊人以为情况不会再糟的时候，他们被克努特大帝征服了。克努特征收的税率实际上达到了……100%。是的，汤姆，那确实是一个巨大的变化，但另一项税务变革即将来临。这就是针对所得税的“税收数字化”计划。如果你对此有任何担忧，劳埃德银行可以为你提供帮助，因为他们致力于让这一转变变得更加
simpler for you with a useful HMRC-recognised accounting tool that will help you stay in line with all the making tax digital requirements. And the brilliant thing about this is, is that it is free for Lloyd's business account customers. So when it is time to digitize your income tax, you can bank on Lloyd's. Search Lloyd's business accounts to find out more. In Toronto, every arrival is a statement, and nothing says it better than this.
简单，他们提供了一个实用的、经英国税务海关总署（HMRC）认可的会计工具，将帮助你符合所有“税收数字化”的要求。最棒的是，对于劳埃德商业账户客户来说，这是免费的。所以，当需要将你的所得税数字化时，你可以信赖劳埃德银行。搜索“劳埃德商业账户”了解更多信息。在多伦多，每一次抵达都是一种宣言，而没有什么比这更能说明这一点了。
Cadillac Optic was the number one selling luxury EV in Canada for 2025. Find your rhythm across a seamless 33-inch display and an immersive 19-speaker AKG surround audio system. This city demands agility and optic delivers with precision to make every drive extraordinary. Let's take the Cadillac. Find out more at Cadillac Canada.ca. Luxury sales claim based on S&P Global Mobility Canadian New Vehicle Total Registrations for calendar year 2025 for the Cadillac definition of luxury. At dusk, all lights were put out and the troops rested for the ordeal at dawn.
凯迪拉克Optiq是2025年加拿大销量第一的豪华电动汽车。通过无缝的33英寸显示屏和沉浸式的19扬声器AKG环绕音响系统，找到你的节奏。这座城市需要灵活性，而Optiq以精准的表现让每一次驾驶都非同凡响。让我们选择凯迪拉克。在CadillacCanada.ca了解更多。豪华车销量声明基于标普全球移动（S&P Global Mobility）2025日历年加拿大新车总注册量，符合凯迪拉克对豪华车的定义。黄昏时分，所有的灯火都熄灭了，部队为黎明的考验进行休整。
It was a beautiful calm night with a bright half-moon. As the moon waned, the boats were swung out, the Australians received their last instructions, and men who six months ago were living peaceful civilian lives began to disembark on a strange, unknown shore, in a strange land, to attack an enemy of different race. The boats had almost reached the beach when a party of Turks entrenched ashore
那是一个美丽而宁静的夜晚，半月明亮。随着月亮渐亏，小艇被放下，澳大利亚士兵们收到了最后的指示。六个月前还过着平静平民生活的人们，开始登上一个陌生、未知的海岸，踏上一片陌生的土地，去攻击一个不同种族的敌人。小艇几乎到达海滩时，一队驻扎在岸上的土耳其人
opened a terrible fuselard. The Australians rose to the occasion. They did not wait for orders or for the boats to reach the beach, but sprang into the sea, formed a sort of rough line, and rushed the enemy's trenches. Their magazines were uncharged, so they just went in with cold steel. I have never seen anything like these wounded Australians in war before. Though many were shot to bits, without hope of recovery, their cheers resounded throughout the night. They were happy, because they knew they had been tried for the first time,
发起了猛烈的齐射。澳大利亚人临危不惧。他们没有等待命令，也没有等小艇靠岸，而是跳入海中，排成粗略的队形，冲向敌人的战壕。他们的弹匣里没有子弹，所以他们直接用冷兵器冲了进去。我从未见过像这些受伤的澳大利亚士兵在战争中表现出的样子。尽管许多人被射得遍体鳞伤，毫无康复希望，但他们的欢呼声整夜回荡。他们很高兴，因为他们知道自己第一次经受了考验，
and had not been found wanting. There has been no finer feat in this war than this sudden landing in the dark and storming the heights, and above all, holding on while the reinforcements were landing. These raw colonial troops in these desperate hours proved worthy to fight side by side with the heroes of Mons, the Aen, Eppre and Nerv Chappelle. So that was the first report of the Allied landings at Gallipoli in Turkey on the 25th of April 1915, and it was written by a chap called Ellis Ashmead Bartlett, and he was the war correspondent of the Daily Telegraph. And when it was reproduced in the newspapers in Australia a couple of weeks later, it caused an absolute sensation. And his praise for the courage of the Anzac troops, so the Australians and the New Zealanders, became a source of immense national pride down under.
并且没有让人失望。在这场战争中，没有比这更壮举的了：在黑暗中突然登陆，强攻高地，最重要的是，在增援部队登陆时坚守阵地。这些缺乏经验的殖民地军队在这些绝望的时刻证明了自己有资格与蒙斯、埃纳、伊普尔和讷夫沙佩勒的英雄们并肩作战。这就是1915年4月25日盟军在土耳其加里波利登陆的首次报道，它是由一位名叫埃利斯·阿什米德-巴特利特的人撰写的，他是《每日电讯报》的战地记者。当几周后它在澳大利亚的报纸上转载时，引起了巨大的轰动。他对澳新军团（即澳大利亚和新西兰军队）勇气的赞扬，成为了澳大利亚人心中巨大的民族自豪感来源。
And it was all the sweeter because, as you could tell from my expert reproduction of his accent, Ashmead Bartlett wasn't Australian. You would, of course, expect an Australian commentator to big up Australian performance. But this chap was British. and so to quote one Australian historian and there it was, were they to fight side by side, we belonged and we've been told so by a pom. I don't think it said by a pom.
而且这种感觉更加甜蜜，因为正如你从我对他口音的专业模仿中听出的那样，阿什米德-巴特利特不是澳大利亚人。你当然会期待一位澳大利亚评论员来吹捧澳大利亚的表现。但这家伙是英国人。所以引用一位澳大利亚历史学家的话，当时的情况是：他们要并肩作战，我们属于那里，而且是一个英国佬告诉我们的。我不认为他说的是“英国佬”。
It says by an Englishman. No, he did it. He said by an Englishman. He did say by an Englishman. So as our Australian listeners will know and our Kiwi listeners as well, this is one of the foundational moments in their national identity.
他说的是“一个英国人”。不，他确实说了。他说的是“一个英国人”。他确实说了“一个英国人”。所以，正如我们的澳大利亚听众和新西兰听众所知，这是他们民族认同的奠基时刻之一。
Perhaps the key moment, I don't know. And it's also, of course, intriguingly and suggestively a key moment in the formation of what will become in due course, the Republic of Turkey. So, Dominic, it is a really historically significant episode. Absolutely it is. For countries that are, you know, as different as Australia and New Zealand and Turkey. But it's also, it's not a story in which Britain comes out well. I mean, it's kind of, let's be blunt, it's a cataclysmic disaster. It is. So, hello everybody. Yes, it's a massively important moments in the history of Australia, New Zealand and indeed Turkey, but it's also one of the most colourful and gripping stories of the entire First World War. And as you say, Gallipoli ranks among the great military catastrophes of modern times. And you say the British don't come out well. I mean, some Britain's come out extremely well, but others do not. And chief among those who do not is arguably the most celebrated man in all British history, Winston Churchill. So let me rephrase.
也许是关键时刻，我不知道。当然，这也耐人寻味且富有暗示性地成为了后来土耳其共和国形成的关键时刻。所以，多米尼克，这确实是一个具有历史意义的事件。绝对是。对于像澳大利亚、新西兰和土耳其这样截然不同的国家来说。但这并不是一个英国表现良好的故事。我的意思是，坦率地说，这是一场灾难性的惨败。确实如此。所以，大家好。是的，这是澳大利亚、新西兰乃至土耳其历史上极其重要的时刻，但它也是整个第一次世界大战中最丰富多彩、最扣人心弦的故事之一。正如你所说，加里波利是现代史上最伟大的军事灾难之一。你说英国人表现不好。我的意思是，有些英国人表现得非常好，但其他人则不然。而其中最主要、最糟糕的，可以说是英国历史上最著名的人物——温斯顿·丘吉尔。所以让我重新措辞。
that, we've been talking about this phrase lions led by donkeys throughout and kind of slightly debunking it, I think this is the example of lions being led by absolute idiots. Well, we shall see. We shall see. I mean, among the men at Gallipoli, not just Winston Churchill, the man who carries the can for this disastrous operation, but Churchill's wartime deputy in the Second World War and successor as Prime Minister, Clement Attlee. He was a captain. And he has a horrible time, doesn't he, kind of crawling around among poo? Yes, dysentery, yes, dysentery. the father of modern Turkey,
我们一直在讨论“狮子被驴领导”这句话，并且在某种程度上稍微反驳了它，我认为这就是“狮子被绝对的白痴领导”的例子。好吧，我们走着瞧。我们走着瞧。我的意思是，在加里波利的那些人中，不仅有温斯顿·丘吉尔——这个为这次灾难性行动背锅的人，还有丘吉尔在二战时的副手、后来的首相克莱门特·艾德礼。他当时是一名上尉。他过得很惨，不是吗？在粪便中爬来爬去？是的，痢疾，是的，痢疾。现代土耳其之父，
the single best known Turkish person of the last couple of hundred years, Mustafa Kemal Ataturk, father Turk. He makes his name at Gallipoli. Australia's greatest military hero, John Monash, he makes his name at Gallipoli. But all roads lead back to the man who came up with the entire scheme.
过去几百年里最著名的土耳其人，穆斯塔法·凯末尔·阿塔图尔克，“土耳其之父”。他在加里波利成名。澳大利亚最伟大的军事英雄约翰·莫纳什，他在加里波利成名。但所有的道路都指向那个提出整个计划的人。
The wheeze. Yes, the man who dominates 20th century British history And that man is, of course, the then First Lord of the Admiralty, Winston S. Churchill, because it's his idea to turn the tide of the First World War by landing thousands of British, French, Australian and New Zealand troops on the Gallipoli Peninsula, south of Constantinople. And we will see how that works out. So for those who listen to our series on the Battle of Marathon, that's the Thracian-Chersenese, as was. The Hellespont, isn't it? It is exactly the Hellespont. So let's start with Churchill himself.
那个妙计。是的，那个主宰了20世纪英国历史的人。那个人当然就是时任第一海军大臣的温斯顿·S·丘吉尔，因为正是他的主意，想要通过在君士坦丁堡以南的加里波利半岛登陆数千名英国、法国、澳大利亚和新西兰军队来扭转第一次世界大战的局势。我们将看看结果如何。所以对于那些听过我们关于马拉松战役系列节目的人来说，那就是当年的色雷斯切索内斯。是赫勒斯滂，对吧？正是赫勒斯滂。所以让我们从丘吉尔本人开始。
At the turn of 1915, Winston Churchill is still only 40 years old. And a couple of years ago, we did a series on the young Churchill looking at his life, particularly in the 1890s. He has had an extraordinary life up to this point, an extraordinary four decades. He's fought in India, in Sudan, in South Africa. He was famously captured by the Burrs and escaped from a prisoner of war camp. He became a Tory MP. then he defected to the Liberals.
1915年之交，温斯顿·丘吉尔年仅40岁。几年前，我们做过一个关于年轻丘吉尔的系列节目，回顾了他的生活，特别是19世纪90年代。到目前为止，他度过了非凡的一生，非凡的四十年。他在印度、苏丹、南非打过仗。他因被布尔人俘虏并从战俘营逃脱而闻名。他成为了保守党议员，然后倒戈加入了自由党。
He became Home Secretary for the Liberals, for the Asquith government, then First Lord of the Admiralty, his dream job really, running the Royal Navy, and he's been there since 1911. And when war approached in the late summer of 1914, Churchill was terribly excited. He loved the idea of a war. He's a martial sort of person. He's always put himself in harm's way, and he can't wait to get stuck in.
他成为了阿斯奎斯政府自由党内阁的内政大臣，然后是第一海军大臣，这确实是他梦寐以求的工作，掌管皇家海军，他从1911年起就担任此职。当1914年夏末战争临近时，丘吉尔非常兴奋。他热爱战争的想法。他是一个尚武的人。他总是让自己身处险境，他迫不及待地想投入其中。
and a few months later, even after it's obvious that the war is going to be a terrible classicism for Europe, he's still thrilled and excited by it. So he sits next to Margot Asquith, the Prime Minister's wife at a dinner on the 10th of January and he says to her, my God, this is living history. It will be read by a thousand generations. Think of that. Why I would not be out of this glorious, delicious war for anything the world could give me. And then he stops and he says, I say, don't repeat that I said the word delicious. You know what I mean. I mean, he's a man who loves actually, I mean, not just excitement, but a disaster.
几个月后，即使在战争显然将成为欧洲的一场可怕灾难之后，他仍然为此感到激动和兴奋。所以1月10日晚餐时，他坐在首相夫人玛戈·阿斯奎斯旁边，对她说：“天哪，这是活生生的历史。它将被千代人阅读。想想看。为什么我绝不会为了世界上任何东西而错过这场光荣、美妙的战争。”然后他停顿了一下，说：“我说，别重复我说过‘美妙’这个词。你知道我的意思。”我的意思是，他是一个热爱……实际上，我的意思是，不仅仅是兴奋，还有灾难。
Because he famously said of the Titanic that it was a triumph for British pluck. Exactly. Which I think it's one way of framing it. And this is another one. Yes, it is indeed. This week. Yes. And of course, for Churchill, the great disappointment of the war is that he is the first
因为他曾就泰坦尼克号事件发表过著名的言论，称那是“英国勇气的胜利”。完全正确。我认为这是一种解读方式。而这是另一种。是的，确实如此。本周。是的。当然，对丘吉尔来说，战争中最大的失望是他作为第一
lord of the Admiralty, but the German fleet by and large stays in port. So he doesn't get the great naval showdown that he's hoping for. Even so, Churchill seizes every opportunity to put himself at the center of this stage. So only a couple of months into the war in October 1914, he sends what's basically a sort of private army that is cobbled together of naval reservists, the Royal Naval Division, to Antwerp, which is still under siege by the Germans. He says, my Royal Naval Division will save Antwerp, and he actually goes himself to Antwerp, and he offers ask with his resignation and says, I would like to take personal charge.
海军大臣，但德国舰队大体上都待在港口里。所以他没有得到他所希望的那场伟大的海军对决。即便如此，丘吉尔还是抓住了每一个机会让自己处于舞台的中心。所以战争开始仅几个月后的1914年10月，他派遣了一支基本上是由海军预备役人员组成的私人军队——皇家海军师，前往当时仍被德国人围困的安特卫普。他说：“我的皇家海军师将拯救安特卫普。”他甚至亲自前往安特卫普，并向阿斯奎斯提出辞职，说：“我想亲自负责
of the defence of Antwerp. This is refused. Antwerp promptly falls. And everybody back home says Churchill made an absolute fool of himself at Antwerp. He sent the Royal Naval Division for no reason. The press, the morning post, for example, a Tory paper slams him as an erratic amateur. The Secretary of War, Lord Kitchener, says it was a piratical adventure. Even Asquith, the Prime Minister, says it was wicked folly to have sent so many men to Antwerp and to have made such a hullabaloo about it when it was obvious it was going to fall. But the point about Churchill, Churchill loves a gimmick. He loves a wheeze of a stunt.
安特卫普的防御。”这被拒绝了。安特卫普很快就陷落了。国内每个人都说丘吉尔在安特卫普让自己成了彻头彻尾的傻瓜。他毫无理由地派出了皇家海军师。媒体，例如保守党报纸《晨邮报》，抨击他是一个“古怪的业余爱好者”。陆军大臣基奇纳勋爵说这是一次“海盗式的冒险”。甚至首相阿斯奎斯也说，在明知安特卫普即将陷落的情况下，派遣这么多士兵去那里并为此大惊小怪是“邪恶的愚蠢”。但关于丘吉尔的一点是，丘吉尔喜欢噱头。他喜欢那种妙计式的特技。
And he will do anything to put himself at the centre of the story. Do you think, just to stick up for him, because we're going to dump on him quite a lot over the course of this, the next two episodes. I mean, in a sense, he is right, isn't he, that there is this stalemate. And it's obvious on the Western Front, but it is also apparent at sea. And in a sense, if you're going to break the stalemate, perhaps you do need some left field thinking, some blue sky thinking. It's just that his blue sky thinking turns out not to be, well, a bit dark, really. Yeah, it's not, the storm clouds of war are very much present in it in Churchill's blue sky thinking. But there is a problem.
他会做任何事来让自己成为故事的中心。你认为，仅仅为了支持他——因为在接下来的两集里我们要对他进行很多抨击——我的意思是，在某种意义上，他是对的，不是吗？确实存在这种僵局。这在西线很明显，但在海上也很明显。在某种意义上，如果你想打破僵局，也许你确实需要一些非传统的思维，一些天马行空的思维。只是他的天马行空思维结果证明并不是……嗯，确实有点黑暗。是的，丘吉尔的天马行空思维中确实充满了战争的乌云。但有一个问题。
Of course. He's absolutely right that there's a stalemate on the Western Front and that it would be brilliant if they could break it. But his idea, which is we will come up with sort of great distraction and displacement exercises that will somehow, you know, obviate the need for a nutritional campaign on the Western Front. He is deluded. The war is only ever going to be won on the Western Front. I'm amazingly he didn't come up with my wheeze of invading Switzerland. Yes.
当然。他完全正确，西线存在僵局，如果能打破它将是辉煌的。但他的想法——即我们将提出某种伟大的分散注意力和转移战线的演习，以某种方式消除在西线进行消耗战的必要性——他是被误导了。战争只能在西线赢得。令人惊讶的是，他没有想出我那个“入侵瑞士”的妙计。是的。
We'd have got on, I think. Yeah, you would have got on. Anyway, so he's casting around for something to do. And it's at this point that his gaze falls on the Ottoman Empire. Now, to remind people about the Ottoman Empire, the Ottoman Empire, which is always referred to in the shorthand as Turkey, although it's not just Turkey, of course. The Ottoman dynasty had been ruling in Constantinople for almost 500 years.
我想我们会相处得很好的。是的，你会相处得很好的。总之，他正在四处寻找可以做的事情。就在这时，他的目光落在了奥斯曼帝国身上。现在，提醒一下大家关于奥斯曼帝国的事，奥斯曼帝国总是被简称为“土耳其”，尽管当然不仅仅是土耳其。奥斯曼王朝在君士坦丁堡统治了近500年。
And in 1914, they're governing this vast, multi-ethnic, multi-religious empire, multicultural, more than 40 million people from the shores of the Mediterranean to the sands of Arabia. And this empire famously describes as the sick man of Europe is in a pretty ramshackle condition. So having once been one of Europe's great powers, it's now fallen behind the industrial powerhouses of Western Europe. it's still very much a rural agricultural society, pre-industrial in many ways. In the late 19th century, the Ottomans had started to lose their Balkan territories. So they'd lost Serbia. They'd lost Bulgaria.
1914年，他们统治着这个庞大的、多民族、多宗教、多元文化的帝国，拥有超过4000万人口，从地中海沿岸一直延伸到阿拉伯的沙漠。这个帝国被著名地描述为“欧洲病夫”，处于一种相当破败的状态。曾经是欧洲大国之一，现在已经落后于西欧的工业强国。它在许多方面仍然是一个农村农业社会，处于前工业化状态。19世纪末，奥斯曼人开始失去他们的巴尔干领土。所以他们失去了塞尔维亚。他们失去了保加利亚。
They'd lost Romania. And in 1908, a group of officers in the army, a little bit like the Meiji Restoration in Japan, a group of army officers who were fed up with this. They were generally European-born, so they were from the Balkans. They were from precisely the part of the empire that was beginning to fragment. and they were called the young Turks, and they decided they wanted to reverse the decline of the empire. They seized power in effectively a coup, and they turned the Sultan into a puppet, and the young Turks now run the empire. And how does that go?
他们失去了罗马尼亚。1908年，一群军队中的军官，有点像日本的明治维新，一群厌倦了这一切的军官。他们通常是欧洲出生的，所以他们来自巴尔干地区。他们正是来自帝国开始分裂的那一部分。他们被称为“青年土耳其党人”，他们决定要扭转帝国的衰落。他们实际上通过政变夺取了权力，把苏丹变成了傀儡，现在由青年土耳其党人管理帝国。那结果如何呢？
Well, it doesn't go terribly well, because just four years later, the first Balkan war breaks out in 1912, and by the following year, the Ottomans have lost pretty much all their Balkan provinces except for Eastern Thrace, so that's the bit right now. to Constantinople. And some of the possessions they lose are what are now northern Greece, right? Yeah, northern Greece, North Macedonia, parts of sort of Bulgaria, Serbia and so on, Albania. Specifically, they lose the city of Salonica, so Thessaloniki as today, and there is one particular officer who was born there, right? Exactly right.
嗯，结果并不太好，因为仅仅四年后，1912年第一次巴尔干战争爆发，到第二年，奥斯曼人几乎失去了除东色雷斯以外的所有巴尔干省份，也就是现在通往君士坦丁堡的那一小块地方。他们失去的一些领土是现在的希腊北部，对吧？是的，希腊北部、北马其顿、保加利亚、塞尔维亚的部分地区，以及阿尔巴尼亚。具体来说，他们失去了萨洛尼卡市，也就是今天的塞萨洛尼基，那里有一位特别的军官出生，对吧？完全正确。
So, and he is one of many people, hundreds of thousands of people actually, who are driven out of their homes, who lose the homeland, who are murdered, who are killed and so on and so forth. These are Albanian and Turkish Muslims. And this guy in particular, he was born in Solonika, as he would have been called at the time. He's an army officer. He fought against the Bulgarians in Thrace, and his name is Mustafa Kemal. And we'll be coming back to Mustafa Kemal later on. Have you seen this house? I have in Thessaloniki. Yeah, I have. Yes. Next to the Turkish consulate. It's very good. I actually really like Thessaloniki. I think it's great. I mean, a lot of it is very modern because of earthquakes and fires and things. But, yeah, it's a tremendous place. great. Anyway, war breaks out in 1914. And the Ottoman Empire at first, rather like Italy,
所以，他是成千上万被迫离开家园、失去家园、被谋杀、被杀害的人中的一员。这些人是阿尔巴尼亚和土耳其穆斯林。而这个家伙特别，他出生在萨洛尼卡，当时人们会这样称呼它。他是一名军官。他在色雷斯与保加利亚人作战，他的名字叫穆斯塔法·凯末尔。我们稍后会回到穆斯塔法·凯末尔。你看过这所房子吗？我在塞萨洛尼基看过。是的，我看过。是的。就在土耳其领事馆旁边。非常好。我其实真的很喜欢塞萨洛尼基。我认为它很棒。我的意思是，由于地震、火灾等原因，它很多地方非常现代化。但是，是的，这是一个了不起的地方。太棒了。总之，1914年战争爆发。奥斯曼帝国起初，有点像意大利，
doesn't get involved, but it is keen to shop around for the best offer. And the young Turk leadership, in particular their war minister who's called Enver, are basically putting out feelers to various parties saying, what can you offer us? But it's always most likely that they will get into bed with the central powers of Germany and Austria, Hungary. And the reason is that before the First World War, the Germans had worked really hard to win influence in the Ottoman Empire. They'd put loads of money into a very controversial railway link, which was going to go all the way from Berlin to Baghdad. And they had sent a Prussian general, who was called Otto Lehman von Sanders, to modernise the Ottoman Empire along kind of German lines.
没有卷入，但它热衷于货比三家以获得最好的报价。青年土耳其党领导层，特别是他们的战争部长恩维尔，基本上在向各方试探，说：“你们能给我们提供什么？”但他们最有可能与德国和奥匈帝国的同盟国结盟。原因是在第一次世界大战之前，德国人非常努力地在奥斯曼帝国赢得影响力。他们投入了大量资金修建了一条非常有争议的铁路，这条铁路将从柏林一直通往巴格达。他们还派遣了一位名叫奥托·利曼·冯·桑德斯的普鲁士将军，按照德国的方式对奥斯曼帝国进行现代化改造。
Isn't there another reason also why they were always going to side with the central powers, which is that their big paranoia is Russia. And Russia's abiding passion has been to seize Constantinople, to seize control of the Bosteros, to seize control of the Dardanelles, so that they will then be able to get into the Mediterranean. And essentially, Turkish policy throughout the 19th century, has always been to ally with whichever powers will take their side against Russia. And most famously, that had happened in the Crimean War
难道没有另一个原因导致他们总是会站在同盟国一边吗？那就是他们最大的偏执是俄罗斯。而俄罗斯一直以来的热情就是夺取君士坦丁堡，夺取对博斯普鲁斯海峡的控制权，夺取对达达尼尔海峡的控制权，这样他们就能进入地中海。本质上，整个19世纪的土耳其政策一直都是与任何愿意站在他们一边对抗俄罗斯的势力结盟。最著名的是，这种情况发生在克里米亚战争中，
when Turkey, the Ottomans, had allied with Britain and France. And now, of course, the issue is that Britain and France are allied with Russia. So therefore, the Turks were always going to ally with Germany, don't you think? Well, interestingly, Enver does actually shop around a fair bit. So they do offer a deal to the Russians and had the Russians taken it. Who knows? It's not absolutely decided in 1914, 15. The Ottomans will jump the way they do. And in fact, there are a lot of people in Constantinople who don't want to get involved at all. Well, that's the most sensible course. I mean, as with the Italians. There's a big internal Anyway, Enver, the war minister is very keen on the Germans.
当时土耳其、奥斯曼人与英国和法国结盟。而现在，当然，问题在于英国和法国与俄罗斯结盟了。所以，土耳其人总是会与德国结盟，你不觉得吗？嗯，有趣的是，恩维尔确实货比三家。所以他们确实向俄罗斯人提供了一笔交易，如果俄罗斯人接受了的话。谁知道呢？这在1914年、1915年并没有完全决定。奥斯曼人会以他们那样的方式跳入战争。事实上，君士坦丁堡有很多人根本不想卷入。嗯，那是更明智的做法。就像意大利人一样。内部有很大的……总之，战争部长恩维尔非常热衷于德国人。
And in mid-October 1914, he agrees a secret deal with the Germans. Basically, the plan is the Germans will give them a load of gold, and the Germans will promise them their Balkan territories back if they win the war. And so basically, the way they get into the war is at the end of October, Enver sends an Ottoman fleet, led by two German cruisers that are flying Ottoman colors for various complicated reasons. They go up into the Black Sea. They bombard the Russian ports in Odessa and the Crimea.
1914年10月中旬，他与德国人达成了一项秘密协议。基本上，计划是德国人会给他们一大笔黄金，如果他们赢得战争，德国人会承诺归还他们的巴尔干领土。所以基本上，他们进入战争的方式是，10月底，恩维尔派遣了一支奥斯曼舰队，由两艘悬挂奥斯曼旗帜的德国巡洋舰领导，出于各种复杂的原因。他们进入黑海。他们轰炸了敖德萨和克里米亚的俄罗斯港口。
The Russians, of course, then declare war in the Ottoman Empire. And Enver and his colleagues say, brilliant, now it's on. And a couple of weeks later, the Sultan Mehmed V, they get him to proclaim a holy war, a jihad against the Allies. And this very much, you know, this excites people in Britain. It seizes their imagination. It terrifies them. It's the context for John Buckens' great thrill.
俄罗斯人当然随后向奥斯曼帝国宣战。恩维尔和他的同事们说：“太棒了，现在开始了。”几周后，苏丹穆罕默德五世，他们让他宣布了一场圣战，一场针对盟军的吉哈德。这非常……你知道，这让英国人感到兴奋。它抓住了他们的想象力。它让他们感到恐惧。这是约翰·巴肯的伟大惊悚小说《绿斗篷》的背景。
a green mantle. Comes out in 1916, doesn't it? Yeah, which has this great fear of a jihad and a holy war and a sort of general Muslim uprising across Asia. But actually in real life, this does not happen at all. And as one historian puts it, the jihad is a, and I quote, a miserable failure. So basically it doesn't get anywhere. But, I mean, it is an important context for why the British, once they've engaged in
1916年出版的，对吧？是的，它对吉哈德和圣战以及整个亚洲普遍的穆斯林起义有一种巨大的恐惧。但实际上在现实生活中，这根本没有发生。正如一位历史学家所说，吉哈德是——我引用——“一场悲惨的失败”。所以基本上它没有取得任何进展。但是，我的意思是，这是一个重要的背景，说明为什么英国人一旦参与了
Gallipoli, are reluctant to retreat, is that they're nervous that any loss of face might precipitate a kind of Asian-wide jihad against the empire. Exactly. So how does the war go at first for the Ottomans? It does not go well at all. So Enver takes 100,000 men and he leads them east to face the Russians in the Caucasus. And his plan is that he will encircle and destroy the Russian Caucasus army at a place called Sadakamush, which is a border town close to the border with modern day Armenia. and the conditions at Salakamish are absolutely awful even by First World War standards. So they're 10,000 feet high. There are snowstorms.
加里波利，就非常不愿撤退，因为他们担心任何丢脸的行为都可能引发一场针对帝国、波及整个亚洲的吉哈德。完全正确。那么战争起初对奥斯曼人来说进展如何？一点也不顺利。所以恩维尔带着10万人向东进发，在阿塞拜疆面对俄罗斯人。他的计划是在一个叫萨利卡米什的地方包围并摧毁俄罗斯高加索军队，那是一个靠近现代亚美尼亚边境的边境城镇。萨利卡米什的条件即使按第一次世界大战的标准来看也绝对糟糕。所以他们海拔10000英尺。有暴风雪。
The temperature goes down to minus 26 degrees Celsius. By mid-December 1914, thousands upon thousands of men on both sides are dying of hypothermia or frostbite or typhus. Anyway, the Russians do end up getting encircled. So on the 1st of January, the Russian Supreme Commander Grand Duke Nikolai, He sends a message to Britain and he says, you know, we're in a mess against the Ottomans. Could you please stage a diversionary attack? Could you do something against the Ottomans to relieve the pressure on us? And this is where Churchill comes back into the story.
气温降至零下26摄氏度。到1914年12月中旬，双方成千上万的人死于体温过低、冻伤或斑疹伤寒。总之，俄罗斯人最终确实被包围了。所以1月1日，俄罗斯最高指挥官尼古拉大公，他给英国发了一条信息，他说：“你知道，我们在对抗奥斯曼人方面陷入了困境。你们能发起一次牵制性攻击吗？你们能对奥斯曼人做点什么来减轻我们的压力吗？”这就是丘吉尔回到故事中的地方。
Because Churchill has been thinking about striking East even before the Ottomans entered the war. And he has been looking particularly at some way you've already mentioned, Tom, which is the Ottoman capital, Constantinople, that basically all the great powers have been eyeing very hungrily. And Dominic, which it has consistently been British policy to stop the Russians getting hold of. Correct. I mean, that's another kind of mad dimension to this story, that Churchill's plan is essentially upending centuries of British ambition to stop the Russians getting it.
因为丘吉尔甚至在奥斯曼人进入战争之前就已经在考虑向东进攻了。他一直在特别关注你已经提到的某个地方，汤姆，那就是奥斯曼帝国的首都君士坦丁堡，基本上所有大国都一直贪婪地盯着它。多米尼克，阻止俄罗斯人占领它一直以来都是英国的政策。正确。我的意思是，这个故事的另一个疯狂维度是，丘吉尔的计划本质上颠覆了英国几个世纪以来阻止俄罗斯获得它的野心。
Well, it's not clear what will happen to Constantinople in Churchill's plan after the war. So it's not actually clear that the Russians will get it. But the reason that it is so coveted is that Constantinople commands the narrow strait that divides Europe from Asia, but also this is the strait that divides the Black Sea from the Mediterranean. So the reason it's so important to the Russians is that this is their warm water sea route out of the Russian Empire into the seas of the world. And this strait, this waterway, basically the waterway that goes from the Sea of Marmara outside Constantinople, south to the. the Aegean in the beginning of the Mediterranean. This straight is called the Dardanelles. Now, to give people a sense,
嗯，在丘吉尔的计划中，战后君士坦丁堡会发生什么尚不清楚。所以实际上并不清楚俄罗斯人是否会得到它。但它之所以如此令人垂涎，是因为君士坦丁堡控制着将欧洲与亚洲分开的狭窄海峡，而且这也是将黑海与地中海分开的海峡。所以它对俄罗斯人如此重要的原因是，这是他们从俄罗斯帝国进入世界海洋的温水航线。而这条海峡，这条水道，基本上就是从君士坦丁堡外的马尔马拉海向南通往爱琴海的水道，也就是地中海的起点。这条海峡被称为达达尼尔海峡。现在，为了让大家有个概念，
the Dardanelles are 38 miles long, but very narrow, no more than four miles wide at their widest point. So you can imagine almost like a canal, I guess. Now, on the right-hand side, as you look at the map, the southeastern side, the Asian side, is the coast of Anatolia, of Asia Minor, specifically the city of Chanakali.
达达尼尔海峡长38英里，但非常狭窄，最宽处不超过4英里。所以你可以想象它就像一条运河，我想。现在，当你看着地图时，在右侧，即东南侧，亚洲一侧，是安纳托利亚海岸，即小亚细亚，特别是恰纳卡莱市。
And on the left side, as you look at the map, the northwestern, the European side, that's made up of a long, narrow peninsula, which is named after one of the towns on the peninsula, which is the town of Gallipoli. So that is the Thracian-Chirsonese, as was. So Churchill has been long obsessed with this strait. So just a few weeks into the war, he had said, why don't we send a British and French fleet north through the straits? and then if necessary, if we came to war with the Ottomans, war with Turkey, we could bombard and occupy Constantinople itself. And his argument for doing this is, if it works, and that's a big if, this could be a game changer in the war.
当你看着地图时，在左侧，即西北侧，欧洲一侧，是由一个长而狭窄的半岛组成的，它以半岛上的一个城镇命名，即加里波利镇。所以那就是当年的色雷斯切索内斯。所以丘吉尔长期以来一直痴迷于这条海峡。所以战争开始仅几周后，他就说：“为什么我们不派遣一支英法舰队向北穿过海峡？然后如果有必要，如果我们与奥斯曼人开战，与土耳其开战，我们可以轰炸并占领君士坦丁堡本身。”他这样做的理由是，如果成功了——那是一个巨大的“如果”——这可能会成为战争的转折点。
Why? Number one, if we held Constantinople on the Straits, we'd have a warm water sea route so that we, Britain and France, could supply Russia. We could send, you know, we could send shells, we'd send whatever they needed to fight the war on the Eastern Front. Number two, if we took the straits and we were bombarding or indeed occupying Constantinople, maybe there would be a coup within the young Turk regime,
为什么？第一，如果我们控制了君士坦丁堡和海峡，我们将拥有一条温水航线，这样我们，英国和法国，就可以供应俄罗斯。我们可以发送，你知道，我们可以发送炮弹，我们可以发送他们打东线战争所需的任何东西。第二，如果我们占领了海峡，并且我们正在轰炸甚至占领君士坦丁堡，也许青年土耳其党政权内部会发生政变，
or maybe we could simply impose our own friendly regime that would change sides and bring the Ottoman Empire in on the Allied side. And if we took Constantinople, a show of force like that would surely persuade the other Balkan neutral countries. So Greece, Romania, maybe Bulgaria, maybe Italy. It would persuade them to join the war on our side. So basically everybody would pile in and we'd win the war. And in fact, even after the Gallipoli operation had failed, there were people who said, yeah, Churchill's idea wasn't that mad. So for example, we mentioned Clement Attlee. Atley had a terrible time at Gallipoli, but he always said, do you know what, on paper it was a brilliant idea and it could have worked.
或者也许我们可以简单地强加一个我们友好的政权，让他们倒戈，让奥斯曼帝国加入盟军一方。如果我们占领了君士坦丁堡，那样的武力展示肯定会说服其他巴尔干中立国家。所以希腊、罗马尼亚，也许保加利亚，也许意大利。这将说服他们加入我们一方的战争。所以基本上每个人都会加入，我们就会赢得战争。事实上，即使在加里波利行动失败后，也有人说：“是的，丘吉尔的主意并没有那么疯狂。”所以例如，我们提到了克莱门特·艾德礼。艾德礼在加里波利过得很惨，但他总是说：“你知道吗，在纸面上这是一个绝妙的主意，它本可以奏效的。”
Essentially, Churchill's plan requires sea power alone to win the war. So it's a bit like the reliance today on air power to win wars. That would be the kind of contemporary analogy. Yeah, I guess so. So Churchill at this point is not talking about using troops, and we'll get on to how the plan changes. But the plan is the ship sail up, they more off Concentred April, they bombard it and the Turks surrender. And then the Turks change sides. Yeah, that's magically the Turks then change sides.
本质上，丘吉尔的计划需要仅靠海军力量来赢得战争。所以这有点像今天对空中力量赢得战争的依赖。那将是当代的一种类比。是的，我想是这样。所以丘吉尔此时并没有谈论使用军队，我们将讨论计划是如何改变的。但计划是船只航行上去，他们在君士坦丁堡外停泊，他们轰炸它，然后土耳其人投降。然后土耳其人倒戈。是的，那神奇地土耳其人然后倒戈了。
It seems improbable. Well, when you look at the plan, it's very, very risky. So first of all, just sailing up the straits. There are Ottoman forts on both sides. There are mortars. There are artillery. There are underwater mines. So it's going to be very difficult just to get your ships through the straits up from the Aegean
这似乎不太可能。嗯，当你审视这个计划时，它非常、非常冒险。所以首先，仅仅是航行穿过海峡。海峡两岸都有奥斯曼的堡垒。有迫击炮。有大炮。有水下地雷。所以仅仅让你的船只穿过海峡从爱琴海上去
and get them outside Constantinople. So actually, British sort of contingency plans had been talking about doing this for years. And they had always said, you know, it's much too risky. It wouldn't work. And in fact, in 1911, Churchill himself had said, It is no longer possible to force the Dardanelles, and nobody should expose a modern fleet to such peril. So he himself had seen how difficult it would be.
并把它们带到君士坦丁堡外将是非常困难的。所以实际上，英国的应急计划多年来一直在讨论这样做。他们总是说：“你知道，这太冒险了。它不会奏效。”事实上，1911年，丘吉尔本人曾说：“强行通过达达尼尔海峡已不再可能，任何人都不应将现代舰队暴露在如此危险之中。”所以他本人已经看到了这将是多么困难。
But now, as we've already mentioned, he looks at the Western Front, he looks at the stalemate in France and Flanders, and he says, well, anything would be better than this. He says to ask with the Prime Minister, anything would be better than sending out armies to chew barbed wire in Flanders. I mean, you can see.
但现在，正如我们已经提到的，他看着西线，他看着法国和法兰德斯的僵局，他说：“嗯，任何事情都比这好。”他对首相阿斯奎斯说：“任何事情都比派遣军队去法兰德斯咀嚼铁丝网要好。”我的意思是，你可以看到
the force of that argument, can't you? Of course. However, you can also see the counter-arguments. You can, yes. So anyway, Churchill gets this request from Grand Duke, Nicolai. He says, brilliant. Well, this is the opportunity we need. He sends a telegram to the commander of the Eastern Mediterranean Fleet, who's a guy called Vice Admiral Sackville Cardon. Would this work? Could we send some old ships, send them up the straits, you know, could this be done? And Churchill adds the line, importance of results would judge. justify severe loss. In other words, we could lose loads of ships and loads of men. I don't care because the prize is worth it. And so Admiral Cardin says, well, I suppose it is doable.
那个论点的力量，不是吗？当然。然而，你也可以看到反驳的论点。你可以，是的。所以总之，丘吉尔收到了尼古拉大公的请求。他说：“太棒了。嗯，这就是我们需要机会。”他给东地中海舰队司令发了一封电报，那个人叫萨克维尔·卡登海军中将。“这行得通吗？我们能派一些旧船，派它们穿过海峡吗，你知道，这能做到吗？”丘吉尔加了一句：“结果的重要性将证明严重的损失是合理的。”换句话说，我们可以损失大量的船只和大量的人员。我不在乎，因为奖品是值得的。所以卡登海军上将说：“嗯，我想这是可行的。”
You know, first of all, we'd destroy the what I call the outer forts of the southern entrance to the straits. Then in phase two, we'd go in, send some ships in. We would destroy the inner forts. We'd send minesweepers in to clear the straits of mines. And then we would send our fleet in towards Constantinople. Entirely through naval operations. Yes. They're not proposing that they destroy these fleets by landing soldiers to do it. They do it with the guns from their battleships.
“你知道，首先，我们将摧毁我所说的海峡南入口的外围堡垒。然后在第二阶段，我们将进入，派一些船进去。我们将摧毁内部堡垒。我们将派扫雷艇进去清理海峡的地雷。然后我们将把我们的舰队派往君士坦丁堡。”完全通过海军行动。是的。他们并没有提议通过登陆士兵来摧毁这些舰队。他们用战列舰上的大炮来做这件事。
At this stage, there is absolutely no suggestion of using ground troops at all. They are just going to do this with naval power. That is all that they're interested in doing. And so on the 13th of January, 1915, Churchill goes to Britain's War Council, as it is called. Now, all the big names are there. Lots of people we talked about in this and other Restis History series. Herbert Henry Asquith, the Prime Minister, David Lloyd George, his Chancellor, Sir Edward Gray, the Foreign Secretary, Lord Kitchener, the Secretary of State for War, Sir John French, the British commander on the Western Front.
在这个阶段，根本没有任何使用地面部队的建议。他们只是打算用海军力量来做这件事。这就是他们感兴趣做的全部。所以1915年1月13日，丘吉尔去了英国的战争委员会，正如它所称的那样。现在，所有的大人物都在那里。我们在本系列和其他“历史余波”系列中谈论过的许多人。首相赫伯特·亨利·阿斯奎斯、财政大臣大卫·劳埃德·乔治、外交大臣爱德华·格雷爵士、陆军大臣基奇纳勋爵、西线英军指挥官约翰·弗伦奇爵士。
Oh, well, I mean, if he's there, what could possibly go wrong? Well, Asquith tells his girlfriend, Vinisha Stanley, who is a fraction of his age, you won't often see a stranger collection of men around one table. Anyway, they sit there, they talk about the Western Front and the stalemate, and then Churchill unveils his plan. And as the civil servant Morris Hankey, who was there, wrote afterwards, The idea caught on at once, the whole atmosphere changed. We turned eagerly from the dreary vista of a slogging match on the Western Front
哦，好吧，我的意思是，如果他在那里，可能会出什么问题呢？嗯，阿斯奎斯告诉他的女朋友维尼西亚·斯坦利，她比他年轻得多：“你不会经常看到一张桌子周围聚集着如此奇怪的一群人。”总之，他们坐在那里，谈论西线和僵局，然后丘吉尔公布了他的计划。正如当时在场的公务员莫里斯·汉基后来写道：“这个想法立刻流行起来，整个气氛都变了。我们急切地从西线那沉闷的苦战前景中转过身来，
to brighter prospects as they seemed in the Mediterranean. And Churchill says, listen, this is going to take a few weeks, Max. The Turkish guns and forts merely an inconvenience. Now actually Churchill is not being honest with them. His own admiralty experts have already told him, some of them have said specifically it's not possible, it's an impossible task. But Churchill doesn't pass this on to his colleagues because he is now completely infatuated with the scheme. And so the war council approves a plan for a naval expedition in February, we will bombard and a quote, and a quote, bombard and take the Gallipoli Peninsula with Constantinople as its objective.
转向地中海那些看起来更光明的前景。”丘吉尔说：“听着，这只需要几周时间，马克斯。土耳其的大炮和堡垒仅仅是个不便。”现在实际上丘吉尔并没有对他们诚实。他自己的海军部专家已经告诉过他，其中一些人已经明确表示这是不可能的，这是一项不可能完成的任务。但丘吉尔没有把这些传达给他的同事，因为他现在完全迷恋上了这个计划。所以战争委员会批准了2月份的海军远征计划，我们将轰炸并——引用——“轰炸并占领加里波利半岛，以君士坦丁堡为目标。”
Now, at this point, just to reiterate, he's not talking about doing this with any soldiers. He's talking about doing it with naval power alone. And as even his hagiographer, Andrew Roberts, says, this is mad because ships cannot hold territory. And ships cannot occupy cities. So if they get there and they bombard Constantinople and then the Turks just don't do anything, what are they going to do? You know, this is the issue. Anyway, the question is why on earth the war council has approved a plan that, I mean, Tom, if you and I can see that there are issues, why can they not see it? Now, one reason, we've already mentioned Asquith.
现在，在这一点上，重申一下，他并没有谈论用任何士兵来做这件事。他谈论的是仅靠海军力量来做这件事。正如甚至他的传记作者安德鲁·罗伯茨所说，这是疯狂的，因为船只无法守住领土。船只无法占领城市。所以如果他们到了那里，轰炸了君士坦丁堡，然后土耳其人只是什么都不做，他们打算怎么办？你知道，这就是问题所在。总之，问题是为什么战争委员会批准了一个——我的意思是，汤姆，如果你和我能看出有问题，为什么他们看不出来？现在，一个原因，我们已经提到了阿斯奎斯。
Asquith is distracted. There is no question, you know, Asquith has no greater defender in the world of podcasting than me. However, even I would have to concede he is not on form at this point in time. to remind people Asquith is 62 years old and he is absolutely besotted with his daughter's mate Venetia Stanley who is 27. Early that morning before the meeting in the small hours of the morning
阿斯奎斯分心了。毫无疑问，你知道，阿斯奎斯在播客界没有比我更坚定的捍卫者了。然而，即使是我也不得不承认，他此时的状态并不好。提醒一下大家，阿斯奎斯62岁了，他完全迷恋上了他女儿的朋友、27岁的维尼西亚·斯坦利。那天清晨，在会议开始前，在凌晨时分，
Asgweth had written her one of his huge long love letters I give you my most intimate confidence my unceasing devotion my fears and hopes my strength and weakness my past my present my future she has now written back to him her letters are lost so we don't know what she wrote Snap out of it. Focus.
阿斯奎斯给她写了一封他那巨大的长篇情书之一：“我给你我最亲密的信任，我不断的奉献，我的恐惧和希望，我的力量和软弱，我的过去，我的现在，我的未来。”她现在回信给他了，她的信丢失了，所以我们不知道她写了什么。振作起来。专注。
I don't think she did. Because during the meeting, while Churchill has been talking, Asquith has been reading her letter. And unbelievably, he's been writing back to her during the meeting as well. And he says to her, we are having a most interesting discussion, but so confidential and secret, I won't put anything down on paper. I'm keen to tell you all about it and to see if it meets with your approval. So it's great that Vanessa Stanley will be invited to. What are her views on?
我不认为她做了。因为在会议期间，当丘吉尔在说话时，阿斯奎斯一直在读她的信。令人难以置信的是，他在会议期间也一直在给她回信。他对她说：“我们正在进行一场最有趣的讨论，但非常机密和秘密，我不会把任何东西写在纸上。我很想告诉你这一切，看看它是否符合你的批准。”所以维尼西亚·斯坦利被邀请参加真是太好了。她对……有什么看法？
forcing the Dardanelles. We don't know because her letters are lost. Who knows? It's a lost a military strategy. More seriously, I think a lot of the people around the table just do not take this seriously enough. They think it's this little naval gimmick and the sideshow. And if it doesn't work, we can just pull the plug and we won't have lost very much.
强行通过达达尼尔海峡。我们不知道，因为她的信丢失了。谁知道呢？这是一个丢失的军事战略。更严重的是，我认为桌子周围的许多人只是没有足够认真地对待这件事。他们认为这只是一个小小的海军噱头和副业。如果它不奏效，我们可以直接拔掉插头，我们也不会损失太多。
And lots of historians who've written about this say this was incredibly irresponsible of them. So the historian Peter Hart, read a great book about Gallipoli. A serious operation of war should not be undertaken in such a casual fashion. Hundreds of men's lives cast away on a whim as if in a mere game of sport that could be abandoned at half time. Do they have soldiers in reserve at all? Or is it entirely naval at this point? At this point it's entirely naval.
许多写过这段历史的史学家都认为，他们的这种做法极其不负责任。史学家彼得·哈特（Peter Hart）读过一本关于加里波利的精彩著作。一场严肃的战争行动不应以如此草率的方式进行。数百人的生命被当作儿戏般抛弃，仿佛这只是一场可以在中场休息时放弃的体育比赛。他们到底有没有预备役士兵？还是说此时完全依靠海军？此时完全依靠海军。
And one reason for that is, of course, if you do have soldiers hanging around, where do you want to send them? There is an urgent, desperate need for soldiers on the Western Front. Right. Remember, the pre-war army is effectively. been destroyed, the British expeditionary force. Kitchner is now raising a so-called new army, a volunteer army, to replace them. The idea that you will send 150,000, 200,000 soldiers across Europe to some mad scheme, I mean, that would appall Kichner and Sir John French and so on. Because there's no way that even, say, the very best happens when they capture Constantinople,
其中一个原因当然是，如果你手头确实有士兵，你想把他们派往何处？西线战场对士兵有着迫切而绝望的需求。没错。记住，战前的军队实际上已经被摧毁了，即英国远征军。基奇纳（Kitchener）现在正在组建所谓的“新军”，一支志愿军，以取代他们。那种认为你可以把15万、20万士兵派往欧洲去执行某个疯狂计划的想法，我的意思是，那会令基奇纳和约翰·弗伦奇爵士（Sir John French）等人感到震惊。因为即使是最好的情况，比如他们占领了君士坦丁堡，
it's not going to help the war on the Western Front, is it? No, no. And that's where the war is going to be won or lost. This is exactly the point, that this is. a massive, massive distraction. And what is more, the great rationale for this, which is we're going to help out the Russians, has now disappeared. Because even as they are having these meetings, in mid-January, it becomes clear that actually
这对西线战场的战争也不会有任何帮助，不是吗？不，不会。而这正是战争胜负的关键所在。这正是问题的核心，这是一场极其巨大的干扰。而且更重要的是，这个计划的伟大理由——我们要去帮助俄国人——现在已经消失了。因为即使在他们于一月中旬召开这些会议时，情况也变得明朗起来，实际上
this encircumment at Salakamash has actually worked out in the Russians' favour, not the Ottomans. Enver has made a terrible mess of things. If it's 100,000 men, about 80,000 of them are killed, they die of frostbite or freezing to death or typhus or whatever. The Russians then basically pile in to Western Armenia, eastern Turkey. And this is the point at which Enver and the Young Turk leadership say,
萨利卡米什（Sarikamish）的这次包围战实际上是朝着有利于俄国人、而不是奥斯曼人的方向发展。恩维尔（Enver）把事情搞得一团糟。如果说有10万人，其中约8万人阵亡，他们死于冻伤、冻死、斑疹伤寒或其他原因。俄国人随后基本上涌入了西亚美尼亚和土耳其东部。而这正是恩维尔和青年土耳其党领导人声称，
well, it's not our fault that we lost this terrible battle. It's actually the fault of fifth columnists and traitors within the Armenians. Who stabbed us in the back. Who stabbed us in the back. And this is what sets the stage for the Armenian genocide, which begins just a few weeks later. Now, meanwhile, in London, Churchill, of course, is oblivious to all this. he doesn't care about any of this.
好吧，我们输掉这场可怕的战役并不是我们的错。这实际上是亚美尼亚内部的第五纵队和叛徒的错。是他们从背后捅了我们一刀。是他们从背后捅了我们一刀。这为几周后开始的亚美尼亚大屠杀奠定了基础。与此同时，在伦敦，丘吉尔当然对这一切一无所知。他根本不在乎这些。
He is just thrilled that his pet scheme has got the go-ahead. And when he goes back to the Admiralty and says, it's on, we have to do this. A lot of his colleagues are horrified. Most obviously, the first sea lord. So this is the senior, you know, naval officer, effectively at the Admiralty. He is Admiral Lord Fisher, Jackie Fisher. A great celebrity in 1910s, Britain.
他只是为自己的心头好计划获得批准而感到兴奋。当他回到海军部说，行动开始，我们必须这样做时。他的许多同事都感到震惊。最明显的是第一海务大臣。所以这就是海军部里级别最高的海军军官。他就是费舍尔勋爵（Admiral Lord Fisher），杰基·费舍尔（Jackie Fisher）。20世纪10年代英国的一位大名人。
Well, he'd launched the Dreadnought, hadn't it? The first Dreadnought, HMS Dreadnought. the kind of the prototype for that entire class. He had been the man in charge of the Navy before the war and he'd been brought back from retirement in 1914. Jan Morris's great hero. She loved him. He was writing books about him.
嗯，他推出了“无畏号”（Dreadnought），不是吗？第一艘无畏号，英国皇家海军“无畏号”。那是整个级别战舰的原型。他在战前曾是海军负责人，1914年从退休状态被召回。简·莫里斯（Jan Morris）的伟大英雄。她爱他。她曾写过关于他的书。
He is a remarkable, remarkable character. So he's very short, very stocky. He's bright yellow because he had malaria when he was young. He's extremely religious. When he was ashore, he would try to go to church two or three times a day, which seems a lot to me. oddly for somebody who's such a great naval hero he suffered from seasickness on the other hand he was an incredibly good and enthusiastic dancer how did he have time with all the
他是一个非常、非常了不起的人物。他个子很矮，身材很壮。他的皮肤呈亮黄色，因为他年轻时患过疟疾。他非常虔诚。当他在岸上时，他会尽量每天去教堂两三次，这对我来说似乎太多了。奇怪的是，对于这样一位伟大的海军英雄，他竟然晕船。另一方面，他是一位极其出色且热情的舞者。他哪有时间在所有这些
church and the i also want dancing on board ship if you see sick sloshing all over the exactly anyway fisher is a great character everybody loves fisher they're very excited that he's been brought brack rather like bringing back kitchener to run the war office but actually as as with kitchener jucky fisher is a bit of a loose cannon he's 73 years old he's very autocratic. He's very indecisive. He's very difficult. He spends most of his time leaking to the Tory press and saying, I hate Churchill. Churchill's useless. And he really hates the Dardanelles scheme. Fisher says, this is absolutely insane. The only way this could work is if you landed 200,000, it would take 200,000 men to secure the coastline so you could get your ships through the strait.
教堂活动和……我也想在船上跳舞，如果你晕船吐得到处都是……完全正确。总之，费舍尔是一个伟大的人物，每个人都喜欢费舍尔，他们对他被召回感到非常兴奋，就像召回基奇纳来管理陆军部一样。但实际上，正如基奇纳一样，杰基·费舍尔有点难以捉摸。他73岁了，非常专制。他非常优柔寡断。他非常难相处。他大部分时间都在向保守党媒体泄密，说，我讨厌丘吉尔。丘吉尔毫无用处。而且他非常讨厌达达尼尔海峡计划。费舍尔说，这绝对是疯了。唯一可行的方法是登陆20万军队，需要20万军队来确保海岸线安全，这样你的船只才能通过海峡。
And frankly, we don't have enough men to send 200,000 men. Churchill doesn't listen to him. Fisher is more and more enraged. He goes to see Lloyd George's secretary-stroke mistress of Francis Stevenson, and he says, people at the Admiralty are trying to argue with Churchill, and I quote, but he simply overrides them and talks them down. If he continues his domineering course, they fear there may be a catastrophe. But Fisher's not good at the internal politics, and Churchill is. So when they have meetings, Churchill's very excited and abilient and tells everybody about
坦率地说，我们没有足够的兵力派出20万人。丘吉尔不听他的。费舍尔越来越愤怒。他去找劳合·乔治（Lloyd George）的秘书兼情妇弗朗西丝·史蒂文森（Frances Stevenson），他说，海军部的人试图与丘吉尔争论，我引用他的话，“但他只是凌驾于他们之上，用言语压倒他们。如果他继续这种专横的做法，他们担心可能会发生灾难。”但费舍尔不擅长内部政治，而丘吉尔很擅长。所以当他们开会时，丘吉尔非常兴奋、充满活力，并向所有人讲述
scheme. Fisher sits there, sulking, staring out of the window, you know, irritable, difficult, so people don't listen to him. They listen to Churchill instead. So anyway, they sign off on the scheme. On 19th of February, Admiral Cardin's fleet, combined British and French fleet, launches the first stage of the operation. So the French of sight they've joined as well? The French are involved as well, exactly, in much smaller numbers. Nobody ever talks about the French at Gallipoli, but there are French ships and will in due course be French troops. And they've basically joined because they are, they're the allies, they've got ships. Yeah, exactly.
计划。费舍尔坐在那里，生闷气，盯着窗外，你知道，易怒、难相处，所以人们不听他的。他们反而听丘吉尔的。总之，他们签署了该计划。2月19日，卡登（Carden）海军上将的舰队，即英法联合舰队，发起了行动的第一阶段。所以法国人也加入了？法国人也参与了，确实，人数少得多。从来没有人谈论加里波利的法国人，但确实有法国军舰，而且最终也会有法国军队。他们基本上加入是因为他们是盟友，他们有船。是的，完全正确。
So they're in the Mediterranean too. So they start by shelling these outer forts at the entrance to the straits. And they're horrified when they get there to find out that the Ottomans whom they've assumed will be completely useless, have spent the winter laying minefields, preparing kind of howitzers, bringing up, you know, reinforcing their artillery batteries and whatnot. So basically, this is going to be tougher than they thought. Takes them a week, they finally knock out these outer forts, they clear some of the minefields. Churchill is thrilled with all this. He's sitting next to Asquith's daughter, Violet, at a dinner.
所以他们也在地中海。所以他们首先炮击海峡入口处的这些外围堡垒。当他们到达那里时，他们感到震惊，发现他们认为完全没用的奥斯曼人，整个冬天都在铺设雷区，准备榴弹炮，调集兵力，你知道，加强他们的炮兵连等等。所以基本上，这比他们想象的要艰难。他们花了一周时间，终于摧毁了这些外围堡垒，清理了一些雷区。丘吉尔对这一切感到兴奋。他在一次晚宴上坐在阿斯奎斯（Asquith）的女儿维奥莱特（Violet）旁边。
He says, I love this war. I know it is smashing and shattering the lives of thousands every moment, and yet I can't help it. I enjoy every second of it. So people may reflect on those words when we get into the suffering of some of the troops, Gallipoli. And he says, this operation of mine is going brilliantly.
他说，我热爱这场战争。我知道它每时每刻都在粉碎和摧毁成千上万人的生命，然而我无法自拔。我享受它的每一秒。所以当我们要谈论加里波利一些士兵所遭受的苦难时，人们可能会反思这些话。他说，我的这个行动进行得非常出色。
Soon the Royal Naval Division will be marching into Constantinople. That will make them sit up, the swine who snarled at the naval division. He's talking about the people
很快，皇家海军师就会开进君士坦丁堡。那会让那些对海军师冷嘲热讽的猪猡们大吃一惊。他指的是那些
who said they were useless at Antwerp. And in fact, Churchill is so giddy now that three days after this so the 25th of February, so that's six days after the operation began. He goes to the War Council and he says,
说他们在安特卫普毫无用处的人。事实上，丘吉尔现在如此得意忘形，以至于三天后，也就是2月25日，也就是行动开始六天后。他去参加战争委员会，他说，
we will be in Constantinople by the end of March. We will be able to capture and destroy all Turkish forces in Europe, and we will eliminate Turkey as a military factor in the war. Some chicken, some neck. I mean, absolutely insane from Churchill. The next phase is scheduled for mid-March, and this is the full-scale attack on the inner
我们将在三月底到达君士坦丁堡。我们将能够俘虏并消灭欧洲所有的土耳其军队，我们将消除土耳其作为战争中的军事因素。真是大言不惭。我的意思是，丘吉尔绝对是疯了。下一阶段定于三月中旬，这是对内部
forts inside the Straits. Now, at this point, one of the big flaws in Churchill's scheme has become apparent, and this is he has forgotten that there's another side in this. which is the Ottomans. And the Ottomans will see what's going on, and they will reinforce accordingly. And that is, of course, exactly what the Ottomans have done. They've made more minds.
海峡内堡垒的全面进攻。现在，在这一点上，丘吉尔计划的一个重大缺陷变得显而易见，那就是他忘记了这还有另一方。那就是奥斯曼人。奥斯曼人会看到发生了什么，他们会相应地加强防御。而这当然正是奥斯曼人所做的。他们制造了更多的水雷。
They've brought up more artillery. And some of Churchill's own, you know, subordinates, are now becoming extremely anxious about this. So Admiral Cardin, who was already ill, two days before the operation, has a complete nervous breakdown and has to be sort of taken away. And he is replaced by his vice-admiral,
他们调集了更多的火炮。丘吉尔自己的一些下属现在对此感到非常焦虑。所以卡登海军上将，他本来就已经病了，在行动前两天，彻底精神崩溃，不得不被带走。他被他的副海军上将取代，
John de Robeck, who has always thought the whole scheme was mad. However, the whole thing goes ahead anyway. The big day is Thursday the 18th of March. It's a lovely day. Beautiful, sunny sort of spectacle. 16 British and French ships steam towards the entrance to the narrows, the straits. And immediately things go wrong.
约翰·德·罗贝克（John de Robeck），他一直认为整个计划是疯狂的。然而，整个事情还是照常进行了。大日子是3月18日星期四。那是一个可爱的日子。美丽、阳光明媚的景象。16艘英法军舰驶向海峡狭窄处的入口。事情立刻出了差错。
So one of the French ships, the bouvet, hits a mine and explodes. And it sinks so quickly that of more than 700 men aboard this ship, all but 75. of them are drowned. And then two more ships, British ships, HMS Irresistible and HMS Inflexible, they hit Turkish mines too. Inflexible manages to get away, but irresistible is totally crippled. And then they send another ship to try to rescue them, HMS Ocean, and that is hit first
法国军舰“布韦号”（Bouvet）触雷爆炸。它沉没得如此之快，以至于船上700多人中，除了75人外，全部溺水身亡。然后又有两艘船，英国军舰“无敌号”（HMS Irresistible）和“不屈号”（HMS Inflexible），也触碰了土耳其的水雷。“不屈号”设法逃脱了，但“无敌号”完全瘫痪了。然后他们派了另一艘船去试图营救他们，“海洋号”（HMS Ocean），结果先是被
by a Turkish shell, then by a Turkish mine, and that sinks two. So by nightfall, when Robex says, okay, we're calling off this off, this has been an absolute shambles. They have cleared one line of mines out of nine. Of 176 Turkish shoreguns, they have knocked out precisely four. And of their 16 ships, three of them have been sunk and three of them have been badly damaged. So this has been a terrible day. I mean, it's gone really badly. The next day, Churchill goes to the war council. He reads out the telegrams reporting what's gone on. And he says, it's actually going fine. Yeah, we've taken a few losses. He doesn't mention the French ship and its men at all. He says, we've lost less than 30 British lives
土耳其炮弹击中，然后又触碰了土耳其水雷，也沉没了。所以到了夜幕降临时，当德·罗贝克说，好吧，我们取消这次行动，这简直是一场彻底的混乱。他们清理了九条雷区中的一条。在176门土耳其岸防炮中，他们只摧毁了四门。在他们的16艘军舰中，三艘沉没，三艘严重受损。所以这是糟糕的一天。我的意思是，情况真的很糟糕。第二天，丘吉尔去参加战争委员会。他宣读了报告情况的电报。他说，实际上进展顺利。是的，我们遭受了一些损失。他根本没有提到那艘法国军舰及其船员。他说，我们损失了不到30名英国人的生命
and two or three worthless ships. So the French, he just forgets about them. It doesn't count them. And then he says, well, now that it's going to say, well, is this perhaps the moment to discuss partitioning the Ottoman Empire? And Admiral Fisher says, you are mad. Quote, we told you to use troops as well, but you wouldn't listen. And Churchill himself wrote after the war, For the first time since the war began, high words were used around the octagonal table. In other words, people are now saying to him, you have totally led us. Yeah. You've led us into an absolute mess. This is a shambles. Lots of people have died. What are you talking about partitioning Turkey? We're nowhere remotely near to conquering Turkey. You're mad. And this is the moment when
和两三艘毫无价值的船只。所以法国人，他直接把他们忘了。他不把他们算在内。然后他说，好吧，既然进展顺利，那么现在是不是讨论瓜分奥斯曼帝国的时候了？费舍尔海军上将说，你疯了。引用他的话：“我们告诉过你要动用军队，但你不听。”丘吉尔本人在战后写道：“自战争开始以来，八角桌旁第一次出现了激烈的争吵。”换句话说，人们现在对他说，你完全误导了我们。是的。你把我们带进了一个绝对的烂摊子。这是一场混乱。很多人死了。你在谈论瓜分土耳其？我们离征服土耳其还差得远呢。你疯了。而这正是
they should clearly have said, stop. Enough. Pull the plug. And they don't. And the reason they don't, it's partly because there's Churchill there who's a force of nature, who's basically clearly going to have a massive tantrum if they don't continue with this scheme. It's partly because they've already lost lives and ships. So it's that classic thing of, you know, pouring good money after bad. You know, you have to justify the initial investment, the initial sacrifice. And the only way to do that is to keep, you know, throwing resources down the sink, as it were. But also, Lord Kitchener raises the point about the jihad that you mentioned earlier.
他们显然应该说，停止。够了。终止计划。但他们没有。他们没有这样做的原因，部分是因为丘吉尔在那里，他是一股自然力量，如果他们不继续这个计划，他显然会大发雷霆。部分是因为他们已经损失了生命和船只。所以这是一种经典的“止损失败”的情况。你知道，你必须为最初的投资、最初的牺牲辩护。而做到这一点的唯一方法就是继续，你知道，把资源扔进无底洞。但基奇纳勋爵也提出了你之前提到的关于圣战的问题。
He says, we cannot afford to lose to an Asian Muslim power because the authority of our empire is based on the perception of our superiority. Quote, the effect of a defeat in the Orient would be very serious. I mean, there's a slight kind of Trump wanting to pull out of the Iran war. A really good analogy is Vietnam. You know, a humiliation or a defeat here would be so catastrophic for America's image abroad that we just have to keep pouring and pouring men
他说，我们输不起给一个亚洲穆斯林强权，因为我们帝国的权威建立在我们的优越感之上。引用他的话：“在东方战败的影响将是非常严重的。”我的意思是，这有点像特朗普想从伊朗战争中撤军。一个非常好的类比是越南。你知道，在这里的羞辱或失败对美国在国外的形象来说将是灾难性的，以至于我们必须不断地投入士兵
and hoping that something will change. And so the War Council makes the fateful decision that they will double down. They will send in the fleet for another go, but first they will prepare the ground. They decide we will send a small expeditionary force to the European side of. of the Straits. We will land troops on the Gallipoli Peninsula, and it should be a very easy job
并希望情况会有所改变。于是战争委员会做出了决定性的决定，他们将加倍下注。他们将再次派遣舰队，但首先他们会打好基础。他们决定我们将派遣一支小型远征军前往海峡的欧洲一侧。我们将把军队登陆在加里波利半岛，这应该是一项非常容易的工作，
to take the peninsula and to knock out all the Ottoman forts and batteries along that side of the coastline, and then we can send our ships through. It will be dead easy, and nothing could possibly go wrong. But could it? We will find out after a break. This episode is brought to you by Disclosure Day. The new movie Disclosure Day is directed by legendary filmmaker Stephen Spielberg. And now with Disclosure Day, Spielberg is back with another movie which asks the fascinating question, what would you do if you found out that we here on planet Earth were not alone? See, I feel quite good about it because I've actually been prepping for some years.
占领半岛并摧毁海岸线那一侧所有的奥斯曼堡垒和炮台，然后我们就可以让我们的船只通过了。这会非常容易，绝不会出任何差错。但真的会吗？休息之后我们再揭晓。本集由《披露日》（Disclosure Day）赞助。新电影《披露日》由传奇电影制作人斯蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格执导。现在有了《披露日》，斯皮尔伯格带着另一部电影回归，提出了一个引人入胜的问题：如果你发现我们地球上的人类并不孤单，你会怎么做？你看，我对此感觉很好，因为我已经准备好几年了。
So I've laid up stores. I've got weaponry. I'm ready. When the aliens attack, I will be able to fight back with the arsenal of my disposal. So I'm excited about it. But Dominic, you are not actually appearing in this cast because the cast is a really extraordinary one. And clearly Spielberg didn't need you because he's got Emily Blunt. He has got Colin Firth. He's got Josh O'Connor. He's got Coleman Domingo. And it's a completely gripping and original story.
所以我储备了物资。我有武器。我准备好了。当外星人攻击时，我将能够用我掌握的武器库进行反击。所以我对此很兴奋。但是多米尼克，你并没有出现在这部电影的演员阵容中，因为演员阵容非常强大。显然斯皮尔伯格不需要你，因为他有艾米莉·布朗特（Emily Blunt）。他有科林·费尔斯（Colin Firth）。他有乔什·奥康纳（Josh O'Connor）。他有科尔曼·多明戈（Colman Domingo）。这是一个完全引人入胜且原创的故事。
And absolutely it demands to be seen not on TV, but on the big screen. Disclosure Day is in cinemas. June 10th. So book your tickets now. It's nearly that time, everyone. The rest is football will be on Netflix every day for the world's biggest tournament. Join myself, Alan and Micah for daily debates, unfiltered takes and the most special of guests. All from the heart of New York City. Yeah, that's right. We're excited too. See you soon. From the pitch to the stands to communities around the world. The beautiful game is coming to our beautiful country,
它绝对值得在电影院的大银幕上观看，而不是在电视上。《披露日》将于6月10日在电影院上映。所以现在就预订你的票吧。快到时间了，各位。《其余的是足球》（The Rest Is Football）将每天在Netflix上播出，报道世界上最盛大的锦标赛。加入我和艾伦（Alan）、迈卡（Micah）的行列，进行每日辩论、未经剪辑的观点和最特别的嘉宾。一切都来自纽约市中心。是的，没错。我们也感到很兴奋。很快再见。从球场到看台，再到世界各地的社区。美丽的比赛即将来到我们美丽的国家，
uniting fans around a shared passion. Now you have the opportunity to hold this chapter of Canadian soccer history in the palm of your hands. Score the FIFA World Cup 2026, $1 coin today. Look forward in your change. Hello everyone and welcome back to the rest of history. Dominant, you said before the break that this scheme, that Churchill has cooked up for sending land forces onto Gallipoli that nothing could go wrong.
将球迷们团结在共同的热情之下。现在你有机会将这段加拿大足球历史的篇章掌握在自己手中。今天就收藏2026年国际足联世界杯1加元硬币吧。在你的零钱里找找看。大家好，欢迎回到《其余的是历史》（The Rest Is History）。多米尼克，你在休息前说，丘吉尔为向加里波利派遣地面部队而炮制的这个计划，绝不会出任何差错。
Is his confidence justified? Well, we will discover. Churchill says to them, and I quote, there should be no difficulty in affecting and landing. It doesn't occur to him that it will be at all tricky to land thousands of troops on enemy territory, a long way from home, what will effectively be an amphibious landing, facing modern weaponry. This is something that has never been done before. So can I just ask, the nearest land bases that Britain has are what, Egypt and Cyprus? Egypt, yeah. So they have troops in Egypt. And as we will see, those are the Anzaks. Who are they going to bring over?
他的自信有道理吗？嗯，我们会发现的。丘吉尔对他们说，我引用他的话：“登陆应该没有任何困难。”他根本没想过在敌方领土上登陆数千名士兵会很棘手，离家很远，这实际上是一次两栖登陆，面对现代武器。这是以前从未做过的事情。所以我能问一下吗，英国拥有的最近的陆地基地是什么，埃及和塞浦路斯？埃及，是的。所以他们在埃及有军队。正如我们将看到的，那些是澳新军团（Anzaks）。他们要带谁过来？
So the man who has chosen to command the operation is one of Churchill's closest friends in the army. He's a guy called Sir Ian Hamilton. So Ian Hamilton is often given a very bad press in books about Gallipoli. You know, you mentioned lions led by donkeys. I mean, he's definitely not a donkey. If you were being very critical of him, you'd say he was a bit of a dilettante. And in fact, that's the criticism that people make. He fought in both Burr Wars, decorated. He's a novelist. He's a poet.
所以被选中指挥这次行动的人是丘吉尔在军队中最亲密的朋友之一。他叫伊恩·汉密尔顿爵士（Sir Ian Hamilton）。伊恩·汉密尔顿在关于加里波利的书中经常受到非常负面的评价。你知道，你提到了“驴子领导的狮子”。我的意思是，他绝对不是一头驴。如果你对他非常挑剔，你会说他有点业余。事实上，这正是人们对他的批评。他参加过两次布尔战争，获得过勋章。他是一位小说家。他是一位诗人。
He is regarded as, you know, the most cerebral, the most intellectual of the British Army's senior officers. He's got a kind of quite a wry, sardonic sense of humour. I like his line after the war. He said, there is nothing certain about war. except that one side won't win. And I think that's, you know, that suggests that he's not, he's not absurdly over-optimistic. Hamilton, however, has been dealt a very rough hand. He is being asked, as a reminder, he is being asked to carry out the first ever landing,
他被认为是英国陆军高级军官中最有头脑、最睿智的一位。他有一种相当讽刺、冷嘲热讽的幽默感。我喜欢他在战后说的一句话。他说：“战争中没有什么确定的，除了有一方不会赢。”我认为这表明他并不是荒谬地过度乐观。然而，汉密尔顿拿到了一手非常糟糕的牌。提醒一下，他被要求执行有史以来第一次登陆，
you know, by sea on enemy territory facing modern technology. He's been given a month to planet. So this is not D-Day, you know, months and months in the planet. planning. This is going to be much quicker. But presumably even a month is giving the Ottomans time to beef up their defences. Of course. The Ottomans know what's coming. I mean, they're not idiots. And also, another contrast with Sadi-Day. And his task has made harder because the Secretary of Lord Lord Kitchinner gives him a very rag-tag collection of troops, many of them untested and untrained.
你知道，从海上在面对现代技术的敌方领土上登陆。他只有一个月的计划时间。所以这不是诺曼底登陆，你知道，有几个月的计划时间。这会快得多。但大概即使是一个月也给了奥斯曼人时间来加强他们的防御。当然。奥斯曼人知道会发生什么。我的意思是，他们不是白痴。而且，与诺曼底登陆的另一个对比。他的任务变得更加困难，因为陆军大臣基奇纳勋爵给了他一堆乌合之众，其中许多人未经测试且未经训练。
So to give people a sense, there's the 29th division of the British Army, and that had basically been cobbled together by loads of colonial garrisons. So people who've been serving all over, you know, Asia or whatever are now told you're going to come back and you're going to fight and you're going to be lumped in with these other blokes. Then there is Churchill's Royal Naval Division. Churchill's so proud of this, you know, his favourite child or whatever. They're basically a load of naval reservists and volunteers who signed up to join the Navy when the war broke out, but there was nothing for them to do. So they've been told, you know, you're going to be like a sort of little naval marine force fighting on land.
为了让人们有个概念，英国陆军有第29师，它基本上是由大量的殖民地驻军拼凑而成的。所以那些在亚洲各地服役的人现在被告知，你们要回来，你们要战斗，你们要和这些家伙混在一起。然后是丘吉尔的皇家海军师。丘吉尔对这个非常自豪，你知道，他最喜欢的孩子之类的。他们基本上是一群海军预备役人员和志愿者，他们在战争爆发时报名参加海军，但没什么事可做。所以他们被告知，你知道，你们将成为一种在陆地上作战的小型海军陆战队。
Right. Then there's the French, the Orient Expeditionary Corps, as they are called. And a lot of these people are colonial troops from Algeria and from Senegal. So they're there too. And then most famously, the Anzaks, the Australian Imperial Force and the New Zealanders Expeditionary Force. And these had been made up of volunteers sent by the two dominions of Australia and New Zealand to the outbreak of war, they thought they were going to fight in Europe, and they have been
对。然后是法国人，所谓的东方远征军。这些人中有许多是来自阿尔及利亚和塞内加尔的殖民地部队。所以他们也在那里。然后最著名的是澳新军团，澳大利亚帝国部队和新西兰远征军。这些是由澳大利亚和新西兰这两个自治领在战争爆发时派出的志愿者组成的，他们以为自己会去欧洲作战，而他们一直在
training in the desert outside Cairo. So that will prepare them for the mud of Flanders. Right. So after the war, Australian writers in particular absolutely lionised these guys. And they said these were the embodiments of the Anzac spirit. They are free-spirited, manly sons of the outback and of the outdoors. What a contrast between our brave boys and the sort of sickly pallid products of Britain's industrial cities. It's like a kind of Australian ashes preview.
开罗郊外的沙漠中训练。所以这会为他们适应法兰德斯的泥泞做好准备。对。所以战后，澳大利亚作家特别推崇这些人。他们说这些是澳新军团精神的化身。他们是自由奔放、充满男子气概的内陆和户外之子。我们的勇敢小伙子与英国工业城市那些病态、苍白的产物形成了多么鲜明的对比。这就像一场澳大利亚板球对抗赛的预告。
Exactly, exactly. Now, actually, this is slightly misleading. A quarter of the Australian Imperial Force had actually been born in Britain. So these are people who were British but have emigrated to Australia and now have decided that they will sign up. And actually, a lot of the others were not sons of the outback at all. they came from cities themselves, cities like Sydney and Melbourne. And as Australian historians have actually done lots of work in showing, they're not always the most admirable adverts for Australian virtues.
完全正确，完全正确。现在，实际上，这有点误导。四分之一的澳大利亚帝国部队实际上出生在英国。所以这些人是英国人，但移民到了澳大利亚，现在决定报名参战。而且实际上，其他人中有很多根本不是内陆之子。他们自己也来自城市，像悉尼和墨尔本这样的城市。正如澳大利亚历史学家实际上做了大量工作所展示的那样，他们并不总是澳大利亚美德最令人钦佩的广告。
You know, Tom, I like Australia a lot. We've been there on tour. I'm a big fan of Australia and Australians and indeed of New Zealanders. But actually in Cairo, these blokes don't bring great credit on the... Cairo. Yeah, it's Cairo. They don't bring credit on the Australian flag. There's a lot of fighting.
你知道，汤姆，我很喜欢澳大利亚。我们去那里巡演过。我是澳大利亚和澳大利亚人的忠实粉丝，当然也包括新西兰人。但实际上在开罗，这些家伙并没有给……开罗带来什么好名声。是的，是开罗。他们没有给澳大利亚国旗带来荣誉。有很多打架斗殴。
There's a lot of drunkenness. There's a lot of looting. There's a lot of sexual misbehavior. There's allegations of rape. Two out of ten of these blokes at some point get venereal disease. And in fact, there is a thing that's apparently very well known in Australia called the Battle of the Wazer. What's that? This is when they run a mock on Good Friday, because they've all got VD from the lady.
有很多酗酒。有很多抢劫。有很多性不端行为。有强奸指控。这些家伙中十分之二的人在某个时候患上了性病。事实上，澳大利亚有一件非常出名的事情，叫做“瓦泽之战”（Battle of the Wazer）。那是什么？这是他们在耶稣受难日发疯的时候，因为他们都从那些女士那里得了性病。
of the night, Egyptian ladies of the night. And they run amok through the brothels of Cairo trying to locate the women who they think have given them the clap, basically. Oh. And there's a huge, there's a massive riot, basically, as they run a mock. Anyway. But I suppose it helps to build up elite mateship. Do you think so?
那些埃及的夜间女士。他们在开罗的妓院里横冲直撞，试图找到他们认为把性病传染给他们的女人。哦。基本上，当他们横冲直撞时，发生了一场巨大的骚乱。总之。但我认为这有助于建立精英战友情谊。你这么认为吗？
Elite mateship is what the Anzac spirit is all about. It's all about mateship. Yeah. So they could not be in a better condition. They're ready to have a crack, a crack at the Turk. Take on the Turk. Exactly. Anyway, so basically this is Hamilton's force.
精英战友情谊正是澳新军团精神的全部所在。这全是关于战友情谊。是的。所以他们不可能处于更好的状态了。他们准备好去尝试一下，尝试一下土耳其人。对付土耳其人。完全正确。总之，基本上这就是汉密尔顿的部队。
They haven't trained together. A lot of them are barely trained at all. They don't have enough guns. Their officers have no experience with this kind of operation. Basically, because nobody has any experience with this kind of operation. It hasn't really been done before. I mean, the more you go on, the matter the whole scheme seems. But the rationale for it to obviously is they say, yeah, but all that doesn't matter
他们没有一起训练过。他们中很多人几乎没有受过训练。他们没有足够的枪支。他们的军官对这种行动没有任何经验。基本上，因为没有人对这种行动有任何经验。这以前并没有真正做过。我的意思是，你越深入了解，整个计划看起来就越疯狂。但显然，其理由是他们说，是的，但所有这些都不重要，
because it's only the Turks. So as soon as we get ashore, the Turks will undoubtedly run away. Because they are just hanging around smoking hookahs and drinking very thick coffee. Well, this brings us to Johnny Turk, as the Tommy's and the Anzaks called him. So there's obviously a massive sense of racial superiority that underlies all this. I mean, the Turks, the Ottomans, are not a joke at all. They are battle-hardened. They have just fought two Balkan wars and they fought the Italians in Libya.
因为那只是土耳其人。所以一旦我们上岸，土耳其人无疑会逃跑。因为他们只是在闲逛，抽着水烟，喝着非常浓的咖啡。嗯，这把我们带到了“约翰尼·土耳其”（Johnny Turk），正如汤米（Tommy）和澳新军团所称呼的那样。所以这背后显然有一种强烈的种族优越感。我的意思是，土耳其人，奥斯曼人，根本不是笑话。他们是久经沙场的。他们刚刚打过两场巴尔干战争，还在利比亚与意大利人作战。
This time, they will be fighting very clearly in defense of their nation. land for their native soil. The idea that they're just going to run away is laughable. And they have been very busy. So this German guy, Otto Lehman von Sanders, he has been modernizing the Ottoman army and he has now been moved specifically to the Dardanelles and told, take charge of the Fifth Army, the Ottoman Fifth Army is going to defend the straits from these blokes. And Lehman has been given 200,000 men. And he thinks, well, you know, he's not an idiot. He can see what's happened on the Western Front and whatnot.
这一次，他们将非常明确地为保卫他们的国家、为他们的本土而战。认为他们会逃跑的想法是可笑的。而且他们一直非常忙碌。所以这个德国人，奥托·利曼·冯·桑德斯（Otto Liman von Sanders），他一直在对奥斯曼军队进行现代化改造，现在他被专门调到了达达尼尔海峡，并被告知，接管第五军，奥斯曼第五军将保卫海峡，抵御这些家伙。利曼得到了20万军队。他想，嗯，你知道，他不是白痴。他能看到西线战场上发生了什么等等。
And he says, right, well, obviously what we're going to do is we're just going to wait for them to land and then we'll just kill them all. We'll let them approach us. We'll establish trenches. We'll establish our barbed wire. We will lay mines. We will have supply roads ready to bring up more ammunition. We will prepare our positions on the high ground. When the Allies land, you know, we will basically just drive them into the sea or side them down with our machine guns.
他说，好吧，显然我们要做的就是等他们登陆，然后我们就把他们全部杀掉。我们会让他们靠近我们。我们将建立战壕。我们将建立铁丝网。我们将铺设水雷。我们将准备好补给道路以运送更多弹药。我们将准备好我们在高地的阵地。当盟军登陆时，你知道，我们基本上会把他们赶进大海，或者用我们的机枪把他们扫射下去。
So we now get to mid-April. On the 10th of April, Sarian Hamilton and his senior officers arrive on the island of Lemnos in the northern Aegean. And two days later, they are joined there by the Anzaks from Egypt, and then by the 29th division of the British Army, and also by the French. Meanwhile, Churchill's Royal Naval Division have been training on the island of Skiros, which is to the south of Lemnos. and one of the men on the island is the Cambridge-educated poet Rupert Brooke and Rupert Brooke is 27 years old he is described by W.B. Yates as the handsomest man in England
所以我们现在到了四月中旬。4月10日，伊恩·汉密尔顿爵士和他的高级军官抵达了北爱琴海的利姆诺斯岛（Lemnos）。两天后，来自埃及的澳新军团，以及英国陆军第29师，还有法国人也加入了他们。与此同时，丘吉尔的皇家海军师一直在斯基罗斯岛（Skiros）上训练，该岛位于利姆诺斯岛以南。岛上的人之一是剑桥毕业的诗人鲁珀特·布鲁克（Rupert Brooke），鲁珀特·布鲁克27岁。他被W.B.叶芝（W.B. Yeats）描述为英国最英俊的男人。
I always find that kind of ludicrous like has Yates seen every other man in England? No, he hasn't. I mean he is in an absolute lather of excitement about all the classical and the historical associations, isn't he? Yeah. I mean, Troy is just, up the Dardanelles and he dreams of fighting there on the plane of Troy. And he comes up with this amazing phrase, which I think speaks for so many of us. He wrote, I suddenly realized that
我总是觉得这很荒谬，叶芝见过英国所有其他男人吗？不，他没有。我的意思是，他对于所有的古典和历史联系感到非常兴奋，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，特洛伊就在达达尼尔海峡上方，他梦想着在那里、在特洛伊平原上战斗。他想出了这个惊人的短语，我认为这代表了我们许多人。他写道：“我突然意识到，
the ambition of my life has been since I was two to go on a military expedition against Constantinople. I mean, his dream will come true, or will it? Well, will it? Brook has already imagined his own death, of course, very famously, some of the most famous lines written in the First World War. If I should die, think only this of me, that there is some corner of a foreign field that is forever England. Yeah, and he wants to die if he has to die like Achilles, bravely, in the heat of battle on the plane of Troy. Yeah. He will lead his men over the plain of Troy and a beating sunshine. In a chariot. You know, everyone cheering. Yeah. The most handsome man in England in burning armour. How does he die, Dominic? He's bitten on the lip by a mosquito.
我一生以来的抱负，从我两岁起，就是去参加一场针对君士坦丁堡的军事远征。”我的意思是，他的梦想会成真吗，还是会？嗯，会吗？布鲁克当然已经想象过自己的死亡，非常著名，这是第一次世界大战中写下的一些最著名的诗句。“如果我死了，请只这样想我，在那外国田野的一角，永远是英国。”是的，如果他必须死，他想像阿喀琉斯一样，勇敢地死在特洛伊平原的战斗热潮中。是的。他将带领他的部下在阳光明媚的特洛伊平原上冲锋。坐着战车。你知道，每个人都在欢呼。是的。英国最英俊的男人，穿着燃烧的盔甲。他怎么死的，多米尼克？他嘴唇被蚊子叮了一口。
The mosquito bite becomes infected, and he dies of blood poisoning on the 23rd of April. So he hasn't even seen an Ottoman defender. He hasn't set foot on the soil of Asia. He hasn't even got to the Gallipoli Peninsula. He's dead before he's set off. And this report in the newspapers, the Asquith family, knew him very well. They were devastated, but this. Churchill knew him, was devastated, wrote a absolute,
蚊子叮咬处受到感染，他于4月23日死于败血症。所以他甚至没有见过奥斯曼守军。他没有踏上亚洲的土地。他甚至没有到达加里波利半岛。他在出发前就死了。报纸上的这篇报道，阿斯奎斯一家非常了解他。他们很悲痛，但这个。丘吉尔认识他，非常悲痛，写了一篇绝对的、
sort of tear-stained, syrupy, obituary for him, I think, in the times. And you might say this is quite a bad omen that this bloke who was going to lead the kind of attack on Troy. I just think generally attacking Troy is not sensible. Yeah. It's going to go on for 10 years at least. There's a slight sign at this point. I think that Churchill is beginning to wobble himself.
那种泪流满面、甜腻的讣告，我想是在《泰晤士报》上。你可能会说这是一个非常糟糕的预兆，这个本来要领导对特洛伊进攻的家伙。我只是觉得攻击特洛伊通常是不明智的。是的。这至少要持续10年。我认为在这一点上，丘吉尔本人似乎开始动摇了。
Lloyd George said he was looking worried and looking ill. The former Tory Prime Minister Arthur Balfour asked Churchill. Is it, how's it going to go this business at Gallipoli? You know, you must be absolutely, bet you can't wait. And Churchill's then said, I think there's nothing for it, but to go through with the business. No one can count with certainty on the issue of a battle, which suggests that he is beginning to wobble. And then he says, but we have the chances in our favour and we play for vital gains with non-vital stakes. And I think the tens and tens of thousands of men who died at Gallipi would be probably quite offended to be referred to.
劳合·乔治说他看起来很担心，看起来病了。前保守党首相亚瑟·贝尔福（Arthur Balfour）问丘吉尔：“怎么样，加里波利这件事进展如何？你知道，你一定非常、打赌你等不及了。”丘吉尔当时说：“我想除了把这件事进行到底，别无他法。没有人能确定一场战斗的结果。”这表明他开始动摇了。然后他说：“但我们有胜算，我们用非关键的赌注去博取关键的收益。”我想在加里波利死去的成千上万的士兵，如果被称为
be referred to as non-vital stakes. Anyway, the landings were initially set for the 23rd of April, the day that Brooke died. But they are postponed by two days because of bad weather. Another bad omen, possibly, we shall see. The plan calls for two distractions to kind of confuse the Turks. So the French will land at Kumkala in Asia. They'll get off their ships, then they'll get back on again and come back the other side. This is to trick the Turks.
非关键的赌注，可能会感到非常被冒犯。总之，登陆最初定于4月23日，也就是布鲁克去世的那天。但由于天气恶劣，推迟了两天。另一个糟糕的预兆，可能吧，我们拭目以待。计划要求进行两次干扰，以迷惑土耳其人。所以法国人将在亚洲的库姆卡莱（Kumkale）登陆。他们会下船，然后再次上船，回到另一边。这是为了欺骗土耳其人。
What a wheeze. And then a brilliant wheeze, actually. The Royal Naval Division will pretend to land at a place called Bolleia, which is in the north of the peninsula. And actually, they get New Zealand's greatest war hero, Bernard Freyberg. He swims ashore and lights flares on the beach to distract the defenders. And then he swims back again. And this is an incredible feat of New Zealand plot.
真是个妙计。实际上是一个绝妙的妙计。皇家海军师将假装在半岛北部的博莱尔（Bolayir）登陆。实际上，他们让新西兰最伟大的战争英雄伯纳德·弗雷伯格（Bernard Freyberg）游上岸，在海滩上点燃照明弹以分散守军的注意力。然后他又游了回来。这是新西兰人的一项不可思议的壮举。
There's not as much New Zealand action in this story as there should be. Well, New Zealanders are generally more retiring, aren't they, I think, than Australians. Unless it comes to rugby. Yeah, I guess. They're putting all their energy into rugby and not enough into boasting about their martial feats. Is that true? Yeah, all swimming ashore and lighting flares. Exactly, which I think is very impressive.
这个故事中新西兰人的行动没有应有的那么多。嗯，新西兰人通常比澳大利亚人更内敛，不是吗？除非涉及到橄榄球。是的，我想是这样。他们把所有的精力都投入到了橄榄球上，而没有投入到吹嘘他们的军事功绩上。是真的吗？是的，或者游上岸点燃照明弹。完全正确，我认为这非常令人印象深刻。
So these are the distractions, and then there'll be two landings. Landing number one is the two ANZAC divisions led by the third Australian Infantry Brigade. They all land on the western side of the Gallipoli. peninsula at this sort of crescent bay, sandy bay, which ends up being called Anzac Cove. And meanwhile, the British, the 29th Division, will land at the very southern tip of the peninsula, which is called Cape Helles, and there are five beaches, SV, W, X and Y around this tip, and they will land at these five beaches. Can I just ask, are they more British than Anzac's?
所以这些是干扰，然后会有两次登陆。第一次登陆是两支澳新军团师，由澳大利亚第三步兵旅领导。他们都登陆在加里波利半岛的西侧，在这个新月形海湾、沙滩，最终被称为澳新军团湾（Anzac Cove）。与此同时，英国人，第29师，将登陆在半岛的最南端，被称为海丽丝角（Cape Helles），在这个尖端周围有五个海滩，S、V、W、X和Y，他们将在这些海滩登陆。我能问一下吗，他们是英国人多还是澳新军团多？
Yes. Because that's not the sense you get, is it, generally? Are you dissing Australian stuff? No, I'm not dissing. I mean, my sense is that Gallipoli was entirely fought by Anzax. I think that's the kind of the vague sense you have. Yeah. And that there are British generals lurking in the background being sinister and posh and like Douglas Jardine.
是的。因为那不是你通常得到的感觉，不是吗？你在贬低澳大利亚的东西吗？不，我没有贬低。我的意思是，我的感觉是加里波利完全是由澳新军团打的。我认为这是你所拥有的那种模糊的感觉。是的。而且背景中潜伏着英国将军，阴险而势利，就像道格拉斯·贾丁（Douglas Jardine）。
Yeah, drinking tea. Yeah. They're drinking tea and swimming, the British on the beach, while Australian plucky Australian boys who've come with court hats from the outback are being mown down by cruel Turkish gunners. Loads of British are being mown down as well. Well, we will see. Yeah, loads of British swimming mode down. Yeah.
是的，喝茶。是的。英国人在海滩上喝茶和游泳，而来自内陆、戴着软帽的勇敢的澳大利亚小伙子们却被残酷的土耳其炮手扫射。大量的英国人也被扫射。嗯，我们会看到的。是的，大量的英国人被扫射。是的。
So the plan is you will land, you'll establish your beachhead, and then you will push inland. The terrain is not ideal. It's these kind of scrublands, these hills, these deep ravines. But the planners say, don't worry, the Turks will crumble as soon as our lads get ashore. Well, will they? We'll find out. We'll start with the Anzac, 16,000 of them. Remember, these are untrained soldiers, untested, and they're attempting something very difficult.
所以计划是你登陆，建立滩头阵地，然后向内陆推进。地形并不理想。这是那种灌木丛、山丘、深峡谷。但策划者说，别担心，一旦我们的小伙子们上岸，土耳其人就会崩溃。嗯，他们会吗？我们会发现的。我们从澳新军团开始，16000人。记住，这些是未经训练的士兵，未经测试，他们正在尝试一些非常困难的事情。
to landing at sea at night against machine guns and barbed wire. I mean, has this ever happened before? No. No one has ever done this before. I mean, that's a massive ask. It's huge. But you've come all the way from Australia. You've had, what, six months of training?
在夜间从海上登陆，面对机枪和铁丝网。我的意思是，这以前发生过吗？没有。以前没有人做过这个。我的意思是，这是一个巨大的要求。这太大了。但你从澳大利亚一路赶来。你有什么，六个月的训练？
You've got to do something that no one in military history has done. It's insane. And this is why D-Day, and this is arguably why D-Day is so remarkable. Well, it's partly because they had the lesson of Gallipoli. I mean, Goli is in the back of their minds all through D-Day. because it was such a shambles. So to go back to the Anzaks, they've been given a very narrow window of time
你必须做一件军事史上没有人做过的事情。这太疯狂了。这就是为什么诺曼底登陆，这可以说是诺曼底登陆如此非凡的原因。嗯，部分是因为他们吸取了加里波利的教训。我的意思是，加里波利在诺曼底登陆期间一直萦绕在他们的脑海中。因为那是一场彻底的混乱。所以回到澳新军团，他们被给予了一个非常狭窄的时间窗口，
between 3 o'clock in the morning and 4 o'clock in the morning. So this is the time between, you know, the moon will vanish at 3, the sun will come up at 4, this is your time. The assumption is it will be very straightforward and it doesn't turn out that way.
在凌晨3点到4点之间。所以这是时间，你知道，月亮将在3点消失，太阳将在4点升起，这是你的时间。假设这将非常直接，但结果并非如此。
So this is Private Waltos Stagles of the 3rd Australian Battalion. He was part of the second wave that went ashore. I'll read what he said. It was pitch dark, then all of a sudden the coast A dim outline of the coast loomed up. As we got closer, we were all beginning to get tensed up, nervous, wondering what was going to happen, as everything was so quiet.
这是第三澳大利亚营的沃尔托斯·斯泰格尔列兵。他是第二波登陆部队的一员。我来读读他所说的话。当时漆黑一片，突然间，海岸……海岸的轮廓隐约显现。当我们靠近时，大家都开始变得紧张、焦虑，不知道会发生什么，因为周围实在太安静了。
Then a single shot rang out and a yellowish light flared up in the sky, and from then on the Turks let loose, machine gun and rifle fire at the boats. As soon as the boats grounded, it was every man for himself. And it's very saving private Ryan. So an army surgeon, Australian surgeon, wrote in his diary that he watched the men going ashore and draw this Turkish fire. Several fell as they ran and on the beach I saw even more men lying untidily. Some quite still, others making an occasional movement. Then I jumped over in a two feet of water and waded heavily ashore.
接着，一声枪响划破寂静，天空中亮起一道黄色的光，从那一刻起，土耳其人开始疯狂射击，机枪和步枪子弹倾泻向船只。船一靠岸，每个人都只能自求多福。这场景非常像《拯救大兵瑞恩》。一位澳大利亚军医在日记中写道，他看着士兵们上岸并吸引了土耳其人的火力。几个人在奔跑中倒下，我在海滩上看到更多人横七竖八地躺着。有的纹丝不动，有的偶尔抽动一下。然后我跳进两英尺深的水里，艰难地涉水上岸。
The lapping edge was already pink and frothy with fallen men. Oh, God. So it takes them about four hours to get their men ashore the Anzax. That's amazing. They do get ashore, really. It is. It's very impressive. I mean, that opening reading, I mean, they do perform very, very bravely.
水边已经被倒下的士兵染成了粉红色，泛着泡沫。天哪。所以澳新军团花了大约四个小时才让士兵全部上岸。这太惊人了。他们确实上岸了。确实。这非常令人印象深刻。我的意思是，开篇读的那段，他们表现得非常、非常勇敢。
Yeah. They start to push up the hill up inland, but it is clear that their guiding assumption was wrong. The Turks have not cut and run, quite the reverse. So this is another guy, Eric Moorhead from Victoria. He says basically they went up the hill, they're expecting to see the enemy there. We were now in a scrub-covered plane fairly in the open. No Turks would have be seen, but the air was literally full of bullets and the sound was deafening. The point-blank explosion of rifles and the concealed snipers firing on us at close quarters.
是的。他们开始向内陆的山上推进，但很明显，他们最初的假设是错误的。土耳其人并没有溃逃，恰恰相反。这是另一个人，来自维多利亚州的埃里克·穆尔黑德。他基本上说他们上了山，本以为会在那里看到敌人。我们现在处于一片灌木丛生的平原上，相当开阔。看不到土耳其人，但空气中确实充满了子弹，声音震耳欲聋。步枪的近距离射击声和隐蔽的狙击手在近距离向我们开火。
Our bayonet charge had failed, the men became disorganised. Some runabout distractedly poking in the bushes for Turks. Others fell on their faces, nerve-wracked by the terrible fire. So what has happened is this. The Ottoman troops have let them come inland. And then at the point where the Turks might have panicked under the Australian onslaught, they have rallied, and this is thanks to somebody who already mentioned in this episode, their frontline commander, lieutenant colonel, Mustafa Kemmel.
我们的刺刀冲锋失败了，士兵们变得混乱。有些人心烦意乱地在灌木丛中乱窜寻找土耳其人。另一些人则因可怕的炮火而神经崩溃，趴在地上。事情是这样的。奥斯曼军队让他们进入了内陆。然后在土耳其人可能因澳大利亚人的猛攻而惊慌失措的时候，他们重整旗鼓了，这要归功于本集提到过的那个人，他们的前线指挥官，穆斯塔法·凯末尔中校。
So up to this point, as we said, he's an obscure sort of nationalist army officer. Born in Salonica, he's a big drinker, he's very intense, very driven. But people haven't heard of him. And this is the moment where particularly within the army, he becomes a national hero. Because at 10 o'clock that morning, Mustafa Kemal is heading towards the front line. And he sees some of the Turkish troops retreating. And he says, why are you running away? Sir, the enemy, where, over there?
到目前为止，正如我们所说，他只是一个默默无闻的民族主义军官。出生于萨洛尼卡，是个酒鬼，非常强硬，非常有干劲。但人们还没听说过他。而这一刻，特别是在军队内部，他成为了民族英雄。因为那天早上10点，穆斯塔法·凯末尔正前往前线。他看到一些土耳其军队在撤退。他说，你们为什么要逃跑？长官，敌人，在哪里？在那边？
and they point to this place that the Australians end up calling Battleship Hill about two miles inland, which is where the Australians have got to. And Mustafa Akemil comes out with this line that becomes part of Turkish nationalist mythology. He says to his troops, I don't order you to attack. I order you to die. By the time we're dead, other troops and other commanders will be ready to take our places. And amazingly, I mean, I would find that terrifying. probably would continue running away.
他们指向澳大利亚人最终称之为“战列舰山”的地方，位于内陆约两英里处，也就是澳大利亚人到达的地方。穆斯塔法·凯末尔说出了那句成为土耳其民族主义神话一部分的话。他对他的部队说，我不命令你们进攻，我命令你们去死。在我们死后，其他部队和其他指挥官会准备好接替我们的位置。令人惊讶的是，我的意思是，我会觉得那很可怕。我可能会继续逃跑。
But the Turks are made of sterner stuff than I am. And they turn round and they run back into their fray. And they drive the Australians back down towards the beach. I mean, the Australians do love a beach. Australians do love a beach. But you wouldn't associate Australians for going backwards, would you? No, you wouldn't. But that is precisely what they are doing by mid-afternoon.
但土耳其人比我意志坚定得多。他们转过身，跑回了战场。他们把澳大利亚人赶回了海滩方向。我的意思是，澳大利亚人确实喜欢海滩。澳大利亚人确实喜欢海滩。但你不会把澳大利亚人与后退联系在一起，对吧？不，不会。但这就是他们到下午中期时正在做的事情。
Far from going forwards and pushing inland, they're being driven back towards the sea. Their officers are being sithed down by Turkish machine guns. and they're absolutely shattered. Of course, I mean, imagine how exhausted they must be after making this landing. So this is Private Herbert Filders of the 12th Battalion. Four of us lay under shrapnel machine gun and rifle fire,
他们非但没有前进并向内陆推进，反而被赶回了大海。他们的军官被土耳其机枪扫射倒下。他们彻底崩溃了。当然，我的意思是，想象一下他们在完成这次登陆后该有多疲惫。这是第12营的赫伯特·菲尔德斯列兵。我们四个人躺在弹片、机枪和步枪火力的压制下，
not daring to lift our heads the whole while. If we'd budged or would have been killed dozens of times over. The bullets were streaming so thick over our heads. Our officers said he'd never seen anything like it, and he's an old soldier. I was jolly tired, too. As a matter of fact, I went to sleep twice. That's impressive. That's so impressive.
全程不敢抬头。如果我们动一下，早就被杀了几十次了。子弹在我们头顶密集地飞过。我们的军官说他从未见过这样的场面，他可是一位老兵了。我也非常累。事实上，我睡着了两次。这令人印象深刻。这太令人印象深刻了。
I mean, do you think, is this worse than fighting it on the Western Front? It is really, isn't it? Yeah, I think in the grand scheme of things. I mean, you're kind of in the open, aren't you? You don't know what you're doing? You're blundering around all these, your mad landscape. Yeah, it's really hot. As we will see, particularly in our next episode, in Thursday's episode.
我的意思是，你认为这比在西线作战更糟糕吗？确实是这样，不是吗？是的，我认为从大局来看。我的意思是，你有点暴露在开阔地带，不是吗？你不知道自己在做什么？你在所有这些疯狂的地形中跌跌撞撞。是的，真的很热。正如我们将看到的，特别是在我们的下一集，周四的那一集中。
I think the conditions are Gallipoli are just unbelievably hellish. Yeah. And they're definitely worse than the Western Front. And a lot of people who served on both said, you know, the Western Front wasn't brilliant. But the one thing it had in its favour was it wasn't Gallipoli, which was so much worse. Yeah, it sounds awful. So anyway, this bloke who fell asleep. He was hit three times in the legs, but he still managed to get that to the beach, which is very impressive.
我认为加里波利的条件简直是地狱般的。是的。它们绝对比西线更糟糕。许多在两地都服役过的人说，你知道，西线并不好。但它唯一的好处是它不是加里波利，加里波利要糟糕得多。是的，听起来太可怕了。总之，这个睡着了的家伙。他的腿部中了三枪，但他还是设法到达了海滩，这非常令人印象深刻。
Have a bobby. Anyway, night falls, the Anzaks do have a foothold. They've got this little pocket with a kind of perimeter, which is about two miles long. But in total, they've basically got only half a mile. in land. They are nowhere near where they were meant to be, and they've already lost 2,000 men out of their 16,000 killed, wounded or missing. So that's the Anzax. Now, meanwhile, the British have been landing further south at Cape Helles. And this is actually the bigger landing. This is 21,000 men of the 29th Division. And they're given a tremendous send-off by their
真是个硬汉。总之，夜幕降临，澳新军团确实站稳了脚跟。他们有了一个小据点，周围有一圈大约两英里长的防线。但总的来说，他们基本上只深入了半英里。他们离预定目标还差得很远，而且在1.6万人中已经损失了2000人，包括阵亡、受伤或失踪。这就是澳新军团。与此同时，英国人已经在更南边的海丽丝角登陆了。这实际上是规模更大的登陆。这是第29师的2.1万名士兵。他们受到了指挥官艾尔玛·亨特·韦斯顿少将的盛大欢送。
commanding officer, Major General Ayelma Hunter Western. Hunter Bunta. He says to them, The eyes of the world are upon us. Your deeds will live in history. To us now is given the opportunity of avenging our friends and relatives who have died in France and Flanders. So I looked him up. Yeah. Moustache. Very good moustache.
亨特·邦塔。他对他们说，全世界的目光都在注视着我们。你们的事迹将载入史册。现在我们有机会为在法国和法兰德斯牺牲的朋友和亲人复仇。所以我查了一下他。是的。胡子。非常好的胡子。
Excellent moustache. I think the best British military moustache I've seen so far. I think the moustaches at Gallipoli, by and large, are better than across the board than British moustaches on the Western Front. So Ataturk had an excellent moustache. It's a pencil, though. Hunter Buntus moustache. is so ect British military officer in the First World War. It's the platonic archetype of it.
出色的胡子。我认为这是我目前见过的最好的英国军人胡子。我认为加里波利的胡子总体上比西线的英国胡子要好。所以阿塔图尔克有一撇出色的胡子。不过那是撇细胡。亨特·邦塔的胡子是第一次世界大战中典型的英国军官胡子。它是它的柏拉图式原型。
Do look at it. Do have a look. Anyone who's a fan of military moustaches. Right. Now, things here at Cape Helles do not go according to plan at all. So I mentioned there are five beaches and the main ones. We'll forget three of them. We'll just talk about two of them, W and V. So the first wave to land at W Beach are the first Lancashire Fusiliers.
一定要看看。一定要看一看。任何喜欢军人胡子的人。好了。现在，海丽丝角的情况完全没有按计划进行。我提到有五个海滩，主要的那些。我们忘了其中三个。我们只谈其中两个，W海滩和V海滩。第一波在W海滩登陆的是第一兰开夏燧发枪团。
and when they get there they find that the Turks are waiting with all their barbed wire and their machine guns. I mean, this is Captain Harold Clayton. There was tremendously strong barbed wire when my boat landed. Men were being hit on the boats and as they splashed ashore. I got up to my waist and water. I tripped over a rock and went under. I got up and made for the shore and laid down by the barbed wire. The front of the wire by now is a thick mass of men,
当他们到达那里时，发现土耳其人带着所有的铁丝网和机枪在等着他们。这是哈罗德·克莱顿上尉。我的船登陆时，那里有非常坚固的铁丝网。士兵们在船上和涉水上岸时被击中。我水深及腰。我被一块石头绊倒，沉了下去。我站起来向岸边跑去，躺在铁丝网旁。铁丝网前现在是一大堆士兵，
the majority of whom never moved again. The trenches on the right raped us and those above us raked our right, while trenches and machine guns fired straight down the valley. The noise was ghastly. The sight's horrible. I mean, just, so they've got inland. They're stuck on the barbed wire and they're just being absolutely raked with machine gun fire.
他们中的大多数人再也没有动过。右侧的战壕扫射我们，上方的人扫射我们的右侧，而战壕和机枪直接向山谷开火。噪音非常可怕。景象很恐怖。我的意思是，他们进入了内陆。他们被困在铁丝网上，正被机枪火力彻底扫射。
So the Lancash Fusiliers, they went to shore with 27 officers and 1,002 men. They end the day with 16 officers and just 304 men. But have they secured a foothold? They have secured a little foothold. I mean, they definitely got ashore. So that's something. Now, if you think that's bad, V Beach is the real shocker. So V Beach, the Turks had really put a lot of effort into reinforcing this beach.
所以兰开夏燧发枪团，他们带着27名军官和1002名士兵上岸。一天结束时，只剩下16名军官和304名士兵。但他们守住据点了吗？他们确实守住了一个小据点。我的意思是，他们确实上岸了。所以这算是一点成就。现在，如果你认为这很糟糕，V海滩才是真正的噩梦。在V海滩，土耳其人确实花了很多精力来加固这个海滩。
They had put two lines of barbed wire and then behind them to various lines of trenches. So one of the British naval commanders, who's called Edward Unwin, comes up with a clever plan that you and indeed Rupert Brooke would admire. He says, look, we're just across the straits from Troy. And, you know, if you've done classics at public school, as I have, then you will know how to cope with Trojans. We need a Trojan horse. Not a literal horse. Not a literal horse, but a ship.
他们设置了两道铁丝网，后面还有几道战壕。所以一位名叫爱德华·昂温的英国海军指挥官想出了一个你，甚至鲁珀特·布鲁克都会钦佩的聪明计划。他说，看，我们就在特洛伊对面的海峡。而且，如果你像我一样在公立学校学过古典文学，那么你就会知道如何对付特洛伊人。我们需要一匹特洛伊木马。不是真正的马。不是真正的马，而是一艘船。
Roll the enormous horse on the beach. I mean, it would be original. Frankly. I mean, it couldn't go worse. I wouldn't put it past them. And you're not wrong. It couldn't go worse than what they actually did. So they said, instead of using a,
把那匹巨大的马滚到海滩上。我的意思是，那将是原创的。坦率地说。我的意思是，情况不会更糟了。我不会觉得他们做不出这种事。你没说错。情况确实不会比他们实际做的更糟。所以他们说，与其使用一匹木马，
a horse, a wooden horse, we'll use a bloody big ship like a huge old collier, a coal ship called the SS River Clyde. We will put 2,000 men, we'll put loads of ammo, and we'll put loads of supplies in this big old ship, and then we will deliberately run it aground.
我们不如用一艘该死的大船，比如一艘巨大的旧运煤船，叫“克莱德河”号。我们将把2000名士兵、大量弹药和大量补给装进这艘大旧船里，然后我们故意让它搁浅。
We'll run the ship aground as close to the beach as possible. We'll have another little ship coming up called a steamhopper, and this will go in between the ship and the actual sand. So all the men will be able to jump off the River Clyde onto the steamhopper and then jump off the steamhopper onto the sands and run up the beach. Brilliant. And then this big ship that's stuck on the beach, the River Clyde, we can use that as our headquarters, as a little field hospital,
我们会让船尽可能靠近海滩搁浅。我们会让另一艘小船过来，叫蒸汽驳船，它会在大船和沙滩之间穿梭。这样所有的士兵都能从“克莱德河”号跳到蒸汽驳船上，然后再从蒸汽驳船跳到沙滩上，跑上岸。太棒了。然后这艘搁浅在海滩上的大船，“克莱德河”号，我们可以把它用作我们的总部，作为一个小型野战医院，
as a kind of supply depot, all of this. I think it's quite a good idea. Do you? How does it go? Well, we'll find out. So they start bombarding the beach. and then they're going to send up the Dublin fusiliers first and little rowing boats and then this bloody big ship, the River Clyde.
作为一个补给站，等等。我觉得这是个好主意。你觉得呢？结果如何？嗯，我们会知道的。所以他们开始轰炸海滩，然后他们打算先派都柏林燧发枪团乘坐小划艇上去，然后是这艘该死的大船，“克莱德河”号。
The Dublin fuseliers make very slow progress, so unfortunately they land out of order. The River Clyde lands first or crashes a ground, but it hasn't got as close to the beach as they hoped it would. It's still 80 yards away. So the men can't jump out and wade. They will just drown. So this is where your steam hopper little boat, which would act as a bridge.
都柏林燧发枪团进展非常缓慢，所以不幸的是他们登陆的顺序乱了。“克莱德河”号先登陆或搁浅了，但它没有像他们希望的那样靠近海滩。它还在80码外。所以士兵们不能跳下去涉水。他们会淹死的。这就是你的蒸汽驳船小船作为桥梁发挥作用的地方。
kind of a gangway comes in. Unfortunately, the steam hopper has also run aground, but on the wrong side of the ship and pointing the wrong way. So they can't use that at all. So they're all stuck on this boat offshore. Like how are we going to get off? At this point, the Dublin fusiliers and their rowing boats come into land, and they are absolutely sitting ducks for the Turkish machine gunners
某种舷梯出现了。不幸的是，蒸汽驳船也搁浅了，但在船的错误一侧，而且方向不对。所以他们根本无法使用它。所以他们都被困在离岸的船上。就像我们怎么下去？此时，都柏林燧发枪团和他们的划艇进入登陆，他们完全成了土耳其机枪手的活靶子，
who basically sigh through them. Some of the Dublin blokes jump out and they try to wade ashore, but their packs are so heavy that, they can't really make any progress. They end up being riddled with Turkish bullets. It's a terrible, terrible scene. Private Robert Martin. There were 25 in my boat and there were only three of us left.
基本上被扫射。一些都柏林人跳出来试图涉水上岸，但他们的背包太重了，他们无法真正前进。他们最终被土耳其子弹打成了筛子。这是一个非常、非常可怕的场景。罗伯特·马丁列兵。我的船上有25个人，只剩下我们三个了。
It was terrible to hear our poor chums moaning and to see the poor boys dead in the water. Others on the beach roaring for help, but we could do nothing for them. Those who were left wounded on the shore. In the evening, the tide came in and they were all drowned. And I was left by myself on the beach. So that's not great.
听到我们可怜的伙伴们的呻吟，看到可怜的孩子们死在水里，真是太可怕了。海滩上的其他人大声呼救，但我们无能为力。那些受伤留在岸上的人。晚上，潮水涨了，他们都被淹死了。我独自留在海滩上。所以这不太好。
No. And then what about this ship, the River Clyde? Yeah, I'm sure that comes to the rescue. It's just sitting there. It's just sitting there, right? And the Turks are just hammering shells at it and bullets. Oh, it's a mad idea to have done that then. Yeah, precisely, right?
不。那这艘船，“克莱德河”号呢？是的，我肯定它会来救援。它就停在那里。它就停在那里，对吧？土耳其人正用炮弹和子弹猛烈轰击它。哦，当时做那个决定真是个疯狂的主意。是的，正是如此，对吧？
Stupid idea. Because the men can't jump off. They're in six feet of water. Their packs are so heavy, they will just be dragged down and drowned. And this guy who came up with the idea, Unwin, can see that it's all falling apart. So his massive credit, he says, I will fix this. and he takes an able seaman with the excellent name of William Williams.
愚蠢的主意。因为士兵们跳不下去。他们在六英尺深的水里。他们的背包太重了，他们会被拖下去淹死。这个想出主意的人，昂温，能看出一切都在崩溃。所以他非常值得称赞，他说，我会解决这个问题。他带着一个名叫威廉·威廉姆斯的优秀水手。
They jump into the sea. They've got all these barges with them. They lash together all the barges with ropes. And they literally hold them in place, these two guys, as a gangway. Okay, that is impressive. Right. And the Turks are firing at them and they don't hit these two blokes, which is so impressive. That these guys are such courage.
他们跳进海里。他们带着所有这些驳船。他们用绳子把所有的驳船绑在一起。这两个家伙实际上把它们固定在原地，当作舷梯。好吧，这令人印象深刻。对。土耳其人在向他们开火，他们没有击中这两个家伙，这太令人印象深刻了。这些人有如此的勇气。
And the men start jumping down from the ship onto the gangway. but they are being raped all the time with Turkish bullets. So the first 200 men, only 21 of them reached the beach alive. And there was a petty officer who was watching from the ship, and he wrote in his diary, he said, one after another, the devoted fellows made the dash down the deadly gangways. But to our horror we saw them suddenly begin to flounder and fall in the water. They went down, never to reappear, as the hailing bullets flicked the life out of the struggling men. We almost wept with impotent rage.
士兵们开始从船上跳到舷梯上，但他们一直被土耳其子弹扫射。所以前200名士兵中，只有21人活着到达了海滩。船上有一名军士长在观察，他在日记中写道，他说，这些忠诚的家伙一个接一个地冲下致命的舷梯。但令我们惊恐的是，我们看到他们突然开始挣扎并掉进水里。他们沉了下去，再也没有出现，因为密集的子弹夺走了挣扎中的士兵的生命。我们因无能为力的愤怒而几乎落泪。
So they're leaping off, they're incredibly bravely kind of running across this kind of improvised gangway, and they're all being shot down. After about an hour, the shallows are absolutely choked with dead and drowning men. The able seaman William Williams, he shot and killed. And Unwin, who's been holding the gangway in place, kind of from not so it won't be swept away by the tide. He basically collapses with exhaustion. He has to be dragged back aboard the ship. And at this point, the commanding officers on the river, I'd say, this has been in a complete nightmare.
所以他们跳下去，极其勇敢地跑过这种临时舷梯，然后都被射倒了。大约一小时后，浅滩上到处都是死者和溺水者。水手威廉·威廉姆斯被枪杀。而一直固定舷梯的昂温，为了不让它被潮水冲走，基本上因精疲力竭而倒下。他不得不被拖回船上。此时，河上的指挥官们说，这简直是一场噩梦。
Let's just wait here, stop trying to get off the ship and wait for cover of darkness and then try to get to shore. But, I mean, this is why you should never be too brave, Tom. And I don't think this is an issue that we will ever have to face, frankly, but just so you know, don't be too courageous. Because at this point, one of the infantry commanders who is called Brigadier General Napier says, no, no, we can still do this. And he jumps down from the ship onto the gangway. And he says, go on, men. and somebody shouts at him, you can't possibly land.
我们就在这里等着，停止尝试下船，等待夜幕降临，然后再尝试上岸。但是，我的意思是，这就是为什么你永远不应该太勇敢，汤姆。坦率地说，我不认为这是我们永远需要面对的问题，但你要知道，不要太勇敢。因为此时，一位名叫内皮尔准将的步兵指挥官说，不，不，我们仍然可以做到。他从船上跳到舷梯上。他说，前进，伙计们。有人对他喊道，你不可能登陆的。
And Napier says, I'll have a damn good try. And he starts to run across these barges followed by his loyal major and some of his men. He gets to barge number three and a bullet just smacks into his head and he falls into the water
内皮尔说，我会尽力一试的。他开始跑过这些驳船，后面跟着他忠诚的少校和一些士兵。他到达了3号驳船，一颗子弹击中了他的头部，他掉进了水里，
and his body was never recovered. And so that was the end of him. I suppose he couldn't recognise it if his head's been blown to pieces. I guess. His second in command, his major is right behind him. A second bullet hits the major
他的尸体从未被找回。这就是他的结局。我想如果他的头被炸成了碎片，他也认不出来了。我想是这样。他的副手，他的少校就在他身后。第二颗子弹击中了少校，
the major raises himself to one knee carry on men and then another bullet hits him and that's the end of him as well so basically they're all killed by mid-afternoon there are still only 200 men on the beach and they're huddling for cover sort of under punishing Turkish fire
少校用单膝支撑起身体，继续前进，伙计们，然后另一颗子弹击中了他，这也是他的结局。所以基本上他们都在下午中期被杀，海滩上仍然只有200人，他们在土耳其人的猛烈炮火下蜷缩着寻找掩护，
and there's a thousand bloke still on the river Clyde and only when darkness falls and the Turkish firing dies down can the rest of them get ashore? And they get ashore a lot of them by basically using the bodies as a bridge. But just to be clear, if they're all now on the beach, I mean, they're just exposed...
还有一千人在“克莱德河”号上，只有当夜幕降临，土耳其人的炮火减弱时，其余的人才能上岸。他们中的许多人基本上是踩着尸体上岸的。但要明确一点，如果他们现在都在海滩上，我的意思是，他们只是暴露在……
Well, it's night. Yeah, I know, but when dawn comes, when they all just be shot to pieces? Well, no, because they do manage to push a little... At Cape Helles, they do manage to push a little way inland. So they lost 2,000 men, and they'd lost 2,000 men at Anzac Cove. But in the south, they do manage to push a little bit further.
嗯，是晚上。是的，我知道，但当黎明到来时，他们不会都被射成碎片吗？嗯，不，因为他们确实设法推进了一点……在海丽丝角，他们确实设法向内陆推进了一点。所以他们损失了2000人，在澳新军团湾也损失了2000人。但在南部，他们确实设法推进得更远了一点。
So it's a great triumph. Well, they have not come remotely close to realizing their objectives or to getting to where they wanted to. And it is terrifyingly obvious to them at this point that the Turks are not the sort of pushovers they thought they were. That they are dug in. They are well supplied. They're extremely well motivated. And the last thing the Turks are going to do is to run away. And that evening, the Anzac commander, who was called William Bird,
所以这是一个伟大的胜利。嗯，他们离实现目标或到达他们想去的地方还差得很远。此时他们非常清楚地意识到，土耳其人并不是他们想象中的软柿子。他们已经挖好了战壕。他们补给充足。他们动力十足。土耳其人最不可能做的事情就是逃跑。那天晚上，澳新军团的指挥官，名叫威廉·伯德，
He sent a signal to Saran Hamilton. And he said, you know, my men have performed heroically, but they are thoroughly demoralized by snipers, shrapment, man, and shellfire. If we have to resume fighting tomorrow, he says, there is likely to be a fiasco. You need to get us out of here right away. And Hamilton actually talks to the naval officers. Can this be done?
他给萨兰·汉密尔顿发了一个信号。他说，你知道，我的士兵表现得非常英勇，但他们被狙击手、弹片和炮火彻底挫伤了士气。他说，如果我们明天必须恢复战斗，很可能会是一场惨败。你需要立刻把我们撤出去。汉密尔顿实际上和海军军官谈过。这能做到吗？
And the naval guys say to him, it's actually not possible. We cannot. There are no plans. You know, we don't have the, we haven't prepared. We literally cannot physically get them out at such short notice. And so Hamilton says the signal back to the Anzaks. Dig yourselves right in and stick it out. Dig, dig, dig until you are safe.
海军的人对他说，这实际上是不可能的。我们不能。没有计划。你知道，我们没有，我们没有准备。我们确实无法在如此短的时间内把他们撤出来。所以汉密尔顿给澳新军团发回信号。挖好战壕，坚持住。挖，挖，挖，直到你们安全为止。
And so this is what they are doing. And is this where the word diggers for Anzac troops comes from? I think it is actually. Yeah, this is my assumption, I guess, although I'm not certain. So both at Anzac Cove and at Cape Helles further south, the men are now digging trenches. And this, of course, is the grim irony of all this, that this whole operation was meant to avoid the horrors of the Western Front.
所以这就是他们正在做的事情。这就是澳新军团士兵被称为“挖掘者”的由来吗？我想确实是这样。是的，这是我的假设，虽然我不确定。所以无论是在澳新军团湾还是在更南边的海丽丝角，士兵们现在都在挖战壕。当然，这就是这一切残酷的讽刺，整个行动本意是为了避免西线的恐怖。
It was a diversion from the Western Front. And now, after all, they are back in the trenches. And I assume that it is much harder to dig trenches here than it is in the mud of Flanders. Definitely is. Definitely is in the chalk lands of the Aen or something. So the question now, now that they've landed, what's the plan? Is Churchill finally going to accept that this mad scheme has failed?
这是西线的一次转移。现在，毕竟，他们又回到了战壕里。我假设在这里挖战壕比在法兰德斯的泥地里要困难得多。绝对是。在埃纳河的白垩地带或其他地方肯定更难。所以现在的问题是，既然他们已经登陆了，计划是什么？丘吉尔终于要承认这个疯狂的计划失败了吗？
Or is he going to throw in more men? We'll find out next time. Yeah, there's only one way to do that. And that is to listen to the next episode. And of course, members of the Restis History Club can do so right away. And if you're not a member of the Restis History Club, and you would like to listen to the next episode immediately and enjoy a host of supplementary benefits, then you can, of course, go to the rest ishistory.com where you will get them all.
还是他要投入更多的人？我们下次再见。是的，只有一个办法可以做到。那就是收听下一集。当然，历史俱乐部成员可以立即收听。如果你不是历史俱乐部成员，并且想立即收听下一集并享受一系列补充福利，那么你当然可以去therestis-history.com，在那里你可以得到所有这些。
But for now, Dominic, thank you very much for what's been a very grim story. And I suspect that in the next episode, it will get even grammar. Goodbye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但现在，多米尼克，非常感谢你讲述了一个非常残酷的故事。我怀疑在下一集中，它会变得更加残酷。再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。